For online content creators the unavoidable
subject of 2021 has been NFT’s.
From incredibly cringe-worthy ape profile pics, to
incomprehensibly tasteless tributes to deceased
celebrities, to six-figure sales of the “original
copy” of a meme, it is the thing that is currently
dominating the collective brain space of digital
artists and sucking up all the oxygen in the room.
And I do want to talk about that, I want to
talk about my opinions on NFTs and digital
ownership and scarcity, all the myriad
dimensions of the issue, but I don’t
just want to talk about NFTs, I can’t just talk
about NFTs because ultimately they are just
a symbol of so much more, and it is that
“more” that is ultimately important.
So let me tell you a story.
[Drumming]
In 2008 the economy functionally collapsed.
The basic chain reaction was this:
Banks came up with a thing called
a mortgage-backed security,
a financial instrument that could be traded
or collected that was based on a bundle
of thousands of individual mortgages. Based on the
general reluctance of banks to issue mortgages,
the risk-aversion in lending someone hundreds
of thousands of dollars that they’ll pay off
over the course of decades, these bonds
were seen as especially stable. However
they were also immensely profitable for the
banks who both issue the mortgages and the bonds.
Because of that perceived stability a
lot of other financial organizations,
like pension funds and hedge funds, used them
as the backbone of their investment portfolio.
In this arrangement a mortgage becomes more
profitable to the bank issuing the mortgage
as a component of a bond than it is as a
mortgage. Proportionally the returns per
mortgage from the bond are just that much better
than the returns from the isolated mortgage.
There’s some problems, though. Problem one is
that the biggest returns on a bond come from
when it first hits the market, a new bond
that creates new securities sales is worth
more than an old bond that is slowly appreciating,
but not seeing much trade. Problem two
is that there are a finite number
of people and houses in America;
the market has to level out at a natural
ceiling as eventually all or nearly all
mortgages are packaged into bonds, thus very
few new bonds can be generated and sold.
So here’s the incentives that are created.
One: it’s good for banks if there are more
houses that they can issue mortgages for
Two: the more mortgages issued the
better, because a bad mortgage is
worth more as a component of a bond than
a good mortgage that’s not part of a bond.
So real estate developers find that they have a
really easy time getting funding from banks for
creating vast new suburbs full of houses
that can be sold to generate mortgages,
but rather than building the kind of
housing most people actually need and want,
they focus specifically on the kinds of
upper-middle-class houses that fit into the sweet
spot from the perspective of the banks packaging
the bonds. Buyers, in turn, find that they have a
suspiciously easy time getting a mortgage despite
the fact that, for most people, the economy wasn’t
doing so great. Wages were stagnant and yet even
though developers were going absolutely haywire
building new housing, the houses being built
were all out of their price range to begin with,
and counter intuitively this massive increase
in supply wasn’t driving down the price.
This is because the houses were being bought, just
mostly not by people intending to live in them.
They were being bought by speculators who
would then maybe rent them out or often just
leave them vacant with the intent
to sell a couple years later.
Because speculators were buying up the supply
it created synthetic demand. The price keeps
going up because speculators keep buying, which
creates the illusion that the value is going up,
which attracts more speculators who buy up
more supply and further inflate the price.
These speculators are enabled by a system
that is prioritizing generating new mortgages
purely for the sake of having more
mortgages to package into bonds.
The down payments are low and the mortgages
all have a really attractive teaser rate,
meaning that for the first three to seven years of
the mortgage the monthly payments are rock bottom,
as low as a few hundred dollars per month against
a mortgage that would normally charge thousands.
Caught up in all this are legitimate
buyers who have been lured into signing
for a mortgage that they can’t afford
by aggressive salespeople who have an
incentive to generate mortgages that they can
then sell to a bank who can put it into a bond
to sell to pension funds to make a line go
up, because it’s good when the line goes up.
It’s a bubble.
The bubble burst as the teaser rates
on the mortgages started to expire,
the monthly cost jumped up, and
since the demand was synthetic
there were no actual buyers for the
speculators to sell the houses to.
So the speculators start dumping stock, which
finally drives prices down, but because the
original price was so inflated the new price
is still out of reach of most actual buyers.
Legitimate buyers caught in the
middle find their rates jumping, too,
but because the price of the house is going
down as speculators try and dump their stock
the price of the house goes down
relative to the mortgage issued,
and thus they can’t refinance and are
locked into paying the original terms.
Unable to sell the house and unable
to afford the monthly payments,
the owners, legitimate and speculators,
default on their mortgages, they stop paying.
Eventually the default rate reaches
criticality and the bonds fail.
As the bonds fail this impacts all the first order
buyers of the bonds, hedge funds, pension funds,
retirement savings funds, and the like.
It also cascades through all derivatives,
which are financial products that take their
value directly from the value of the bond.
This creates a knock-on effect: huge segments
of the economy turn out to be dead trees,
rotten to the core, but as a rotten tree falls
it still shreds its neighbours
and crushes anything below it.
It was a failure precipitated by a
combination of greed, active fraud,
and willful blindness at all levels of power.
The banks issuing the bad mortgages were the same
banks selling the bonds and providing the capital
to build the houses to generate the mortgages.
The ratings agencies checking the bonds were,
themselves, publicly traded and dependent
on being in good relations with the banks,
incentivized to rubber stamp whatever rating
would make their client happy. The regulatory
agencies that should have seen the problem coming
were gutted by budget cuts and mired
in conflicts of interest as employees
used their positions in regulation to
secure higher paying jobs in industry.
And, the cherry on top, the people largely
responsible for it all knew that because they
and their toxic products were so interwoven into
the foundations of the economy they could count
on a bailout from the government because no matter
how rotten they were, they were very large trees.
[Drumming]
This naked display of greed and fraud
created what would be fertile soil for
both anti-capitalist movements
and hyper-capitalist movements:
both groups of people who saw themselves as
being screwed over by the system, with one
group diagnosing the problem as the system’s
inherently corrupt and corrupting incentives,
and the other seeing the crisis as a consequence
of too much regulation, too much exclusion.
The hyper-capitalist, or anarcho-capitalist
argument is that in a less constrained
market there would be more incentive to call
foul, that regulation had only succeeded in
creating an in-group that was effectively
able to conspire without competition.
Of course this argument fails to
consider that a substantial number of
people within the system did, in fact, get
fabulously wealthy specifically by betting
against the synthetic success
of the market, but regardless.
Into this environment in 2009 arrived Bitcoin,
an all-electronic peer-to-peer currency.
Philosophically Bitcoin, and
cryptocurrency in general,
was paraded as an end to banks
and centralized currency.
This is what will form the bedrock,
both philosophical and technological,
that NFTs will be built on
top of. It’s a bit of a hike
from here to the Bored Ape Yacht Club,
so I guess get ready for that. Strap in.
As we get into this we’re going to need to deal
with a lot of vocabulary, and a lot of complexity.
Some of this is the result of systems
that are very technically intricate,
and some of this is from systems that
are poorly designed or deliberately
obtuse in order to make them difficult to
understand and thus appear more legitimate.
The entire subject sits at the intersection
of two fields that are notoriously prone to
hype-based obfuscation, computer tech and finance,
and inherits a lot of bad habits from both,
with a reputation for making things
deliberately more difficult to understand
specifically to create the illusion that
only they are smart enough to understand it.
Mining and minting are both methods for making
tokens, which are the base thing that blockchains
deal with, but the two are colloquially different
processes, where mining is a coin token created as
a result of the consensus protocol and minting
is a user-initiated addition of a token to a
blockchain. All blockchains are made of nodes,
and these nodes can be watcher nodes, miner nodes,
or validator nodes, though most miner nodes are
also validator nodes. Fractionalization is the
process of taking one asset and creating a new
asset that represents portions of the original.
So you get $DOG, a memecoin crypto DeFi venture
capital fund backed by the fractionalization of
the original Doge meme sold as an NFT
to PleasrDAO on the Ethereum network.
I’m sorry, some of this is
just going to be like that.
The idea behind cryptocurrency is that
your digital wallet functions the same as
a bank account, there’s no need for a bank
to hold and process your transactions because
rather than holding a sum that conceptually
represents physical currency, the cryptocoins
in your cryptowallet are the actual money. And
because this money isn’t issued by a government
it is resistant to historical cash crises like
hyperinflation caused by governments devaluing
their currency on purpose or by accident. It
brings the flexibility and anonymity of cash and
barter to the digital realm, allowing individuals
to transact without oversight or intermediaries.
And in a one-paragraph pitch you can see the
appeal, there’s a compelling narrative there.
But, of course, in the twelve years since
then none of that played out as designed.
Bitcoin was structurally too slow and
expensive to handle regular commerce.
The whole thing basically came out the
gate as a speculative financial vehicle
and so the only consumer market
that proved to be a viable use
was buying and selling prohibited drugs where
the high fees, rapid price fluctuations,
and multi-hour transaction times were mitigated
by receiving LSD in the mail a week later.
And as far as banking is concerned, Bitcoin
was never designed to solve the actual problems
created by the banking industry, only to be the
new medium by which they operated. The principal
offering wasn’t revolution, but at best a changing
of the guard. The gripe is not with the outcomes
of 2008, but the fact that you had to be well
connected in order to get in on the grift in 2006.
And even the change of the guard is an illusion.
Old money finance assholes like the Winkelvoss
twins were some of the first big names to jump
on to crypto, where they remain to this day.
Financial criminal Jordan Belfort, convicted
of fraud for running pump and dump schemes
and barred for life from trading regulated
securities or acting as a broker, loves Crypto.
Venture capitalist Chris Dixon, who has
made huge bank off the “old web” in his
role as a general partner at VC firm Andreessen
Horowitz Capital Management, is super popular
in the NFT space. He likes to paint himself as
an outsider underdog fighting the gatekeepers,
but he also sits on the boards of
Coinbase, a large cryptocurrency
exchange that makes money by being
the gatekeeper collecting a fee on
all entries and exits to the crypto economy, and
Oculus VR, which is owned by Meta, nee Facebook.
Peter Thiel, who also went from wealthy to
ultra-wealthy off the Web2 boom via PayPal,
loves crypto, and is friends with
a bunch of eugenics advocates who
promote cryptocurrency as a return to “sound
money” for a whole bunch of extremely racist
reasons because when they start talking
about banks and bankers, they mean Jews.
Some of the largest institutional
holders of cryptocurrency
are the exact same investment banks
that created the subprime loan crash.
Rather than being a reprieve to the
people harmed by the housing bubble,
the people whose savings and
retirements were, unknown to them,
being gambled on smoke, cryptocurrency instantly
became the new playground for smoke vendors.
This is a really important point to stress:
cryptocurrency does nothing to address 99% of
the problems with the banking industry, because
those problems are patterns of human behaviour.
They’re incentives, they’re social structures,
they’re modalities. The problem is what people
are doing to others, not that the building they’re
doing it in has the word “bank” on the outside.
In addition to not fixing problems, Bitcoin
also came with a pretty substantial drawback.
The innovation of Bitcoin over previous attempts
at digital currency was to employ a distributed
append-only ledger, a kind of database where new
entries can only be added to the end, and then to
have several different nodes, called validators,
compete over who gets to validate the next update.
These are, respectively, the blockchain,
and proof-of-work verification.
Now, proof-of-work has an interesting
history as a technology, typically being
deployed as a deterrent to misbehaviour. For
example, if you require that for every email
sent the user’s computer has to complete a
small math problem it places a trivial load
onto normal users sending a few dozen,
or even a couple hundred emails a day,
but places a massive load on the infrastructure
of anyone attempting to spam millions of emails.
How it works in Bitcoin, simply put, is
that when a block of transactions are
ready to be recorded to the ledger all of the
mining nodes in the network compete with one
another to solve a cryptographic math problem
that’s based on the data inside the block.
Effectively they’re competing to figure out
the equation that yields a specific result
when the contents of the block are fed into
it, with the complexity of the desired result
getting deliberately more difficult based on the
total processing power available to the network.
Once the math problem has been solved the
rest of the validation network can easily
double-check the work, since the contents of
the block can be fed into the proposed solution
and it either spits out the valid answer or fails.
If the equation works and the consensus
of validators signs off on it the block
is added to the bottom of the ledger and
the miner who solved the problem first
is rewarded with newly generated Bitcoin.
The complexity of the answer that the computers
are trying to solve scales up based on the
network’s processing power specifically to
incur heavy diminishing returns as a protection
against an attack on the network where someone
just builds a bigger computer and takes over.
Critics pointed out that
this created new problems:
adversarial validation would deliberately incur
escalating processing costs, which would in turn
generate perverse structural incentives
that would quickly reward capital holders
and lock out any individual that wasn’t already
obscenely wealthy, because while the escalating
proof-of-work scheme incurs heavy diminishing
returns, diminishing returns are still returns,
so more would always go to those with
the resources to build the bigger rig.
No matter what Bitcoin future was envisioned,
in the here and now computer
hardware can be bought with dollars.
Rather than dismantling corrupt power structures,
this would just become a new
tool for existing wealth.
And that’s… exactly what happened.
Thus began an arms race for bigger and bigger
processing rigs, followed by escalating demands
for the support systems, hardware engineers, HVAC,
and operating space needed to put those rigs in.
And, don’t worry, we’re not
forgetting the power requirements.
These rigs draw an industrial amount of
power and, because of the winner-takes-all
nature of the competition, huge amounts of
redundant work are being done and discarded.
Estimates for this power consumption are
hard to verify, the data is very complex,
spread across hundreds of operators
around the globe, who move frequently
in search of cheap electricity, and
it’s all pretty heavily politicized.
But even conservative estimates from within the
crypto-mining industry puts the sum energy cost
of Bitcoin processing on par with the power
consumption of a small industrialized nation.
Now, evangelists will counter that the global
banking industry also uses a lot of power,
gesturing at things like idle ATMs humming away
all night long, which is strictly speaking,
not untrue. On a factual level the
entire global banking industry does,
in fact, use a lot of total electricity.
But, for scale, it takes six hours of that
sustained power draw for the Bitcoin network
to process as many transactions
as VISA handles in one minute,
and during that time VISA is using fractions
of a cent of electricity per transaction.
And that’s just VISA. That’s
one major institution.
So, like, yes, globally the entirety of the
banking industry consumes a lot of power,
and a non-trivial portion of that is
waste that could be better allocated.
But it’s also the global banking
industry for seven billion people,
and not the hobby horse of a few
hundred thousand gambling addicts.
So just to head all this off at the pass,
Bitcoin and proof-of-work cryptocurrency aren’t
incentivizing a move to green energy sources,
like solar and wind, they are offsetting it.
Because electrical consumption, electrical
waste, is the value that underpins Bitcoin.
Miners spend X dollars in electricity to
mine a Bitcoin, they expect to be able to
sell that coin for at least X plus profit.
When new power sources come online and the
price of electricity goes down, they don’t
let X go down, they build a bigger machine.
[Drumming]
In 2012 Vitalik Buterin, a crypto
enthusiast and butthurt Warlock main
set out to fix what he saw as the
failings and inflexibilities of Bitcoin.
Rather than becoming the new digital currency,
a thing that people actually used to buy stuff,
Bitcoin had become an unwieldy
speculative financial instrument,
too slow and expensive to use for anything
other than stunt purchases of expensive cars.
It was infested with money
laundering and mired in bad press.
After the FBI shut down Silk Road you
couldn’t even buy drugs with it anymore.
In practice you couldn’t do anything
with your Bitcoin but bet on it,
lock up money you already have in the hopes
that Bitcoin goes up later, and pray you don’t
lose it all in a scam, lose access to your
wallet, or have it all stolen by an exchange.
The result, launched in 2014, was Ethereum, a
competing cryptocurrency that boasted lower fees,
faster transaction times, a
reduced electrical footprint,
and, most notably, a sophisticated
processing functionality.
While the Bitcoin blockchain only tracks
the location and movement of Bitcoins,
Ethereum would be broader. In addition to
tracking Ether coins, the ledger would also
be able to track arbitrary blocks of data.
As long as they were compatible with the
structure of the Ethereum network,
those blocks of data could even be
programs that would utilize the validation
network as a distributed virtual machine.
Vitalik envisioned this as a vast, infinite
machine, duplicated and distributed across
thousands or millions of computers, a system onto
which the entire history of a new internet could
be immutably written, immune to censorship,
and impossible for governments to take down.
He saw it dismantling banks and other intermediary
industries, allowing everyone to be their own
bank, to be their own stock broker, to bypass
governments, regulators, and insurance agencies.
His peers envisioned a future
where Ethereum became not just
a repository of financial transactions, but
of identity, with deeds, driver’s licenses,
professional credentials, medical
records, educational achievements,
and employment history turned into tokens and
stored immutable and eternal on the chain.
Through crypto and the ethereum
virtual machine they could bring all
the benefits of Wall Street
investors and Silicon Valley
venture capitalists to the poorest people
of the world, the unbanked and forgotten.
This heady high-minded philosophy
is outlined in great detail in the
journalistic abortion The Infinite Machine
by failed-journalist-turned-crypto-shill
Camilla Russo.
The book is actually really interesting.
Not for the merits of the writing, Russo fails
to interrogate the validity or rationality of
even the simplest claims and falls just
shy of hagiography by occasionally noting
that something was a bit tacky or
embarrassing, but only just shy.
She tells florid stories about the impoverished
people that Vitalik and friends claimed to be
working to save, but never once considers that
the solutions offered might not actually work,
or that the people claiming to want to solve
those problems might not even be working on them.
That’s actually a big issue, since the entire
crypto space, during the entire time that
Russo’s book covers, was absolutely awash with
astroturfing schemes where two guys would go to
some small community in Laos or Angola, take
a bunch of pictures of people at a “crypto
investing seminar”, generate some headlines
for their coin or fund, and then peace out.
For years dudes were going around asking
vendors if they could slap a Bitcoin
sticker onto the back of the cash register,
because the optics of making it look like a
place takes Bitcoin was cheaper and easier
than actually using Bitcoin as a currency.
We have an entire decade of
credulous articles about how
Venezuela and Chile are on the verge
of switching entirely to crypto,
based entirely on the claim of two
trust fund dudes from San Bernardino.
A whole ten years littered with discarded
press releases about Dell and Microsoft and
Square bringing crypto to the consumers
before just quietly discontinuing their
services after a year or two when they
realize the demand isn’t actually there.
The fact that the development of Ethereum was
extremely dependent on a $100,000 fellowship
grant from Peter Thiel is mentioned, but the
ideological implications of that connection
are never explored, the entire subject occupies
a single paragraph sprinkled as flavour into a
story about Vitalik and his co-developers airing
their grievances about some petty infighting.
The book is mostly useful for it’s value
as a point of reference against reality.
It’s a very thorough, if uncritical,
document of absolutely insane claims.
“The idea was that traits of
blockchain technology—such
as having no central point of failure, being
uncensorable, cutting out intermediaries,
and being immutable—could also benefit
other applications besides money.
Financial instruments like stocks and bonds, and
commodities like gold, were the obvious targets,
but people were also talking about putting other
representations of value like property deeds and
medical records on the blockchain, too. Those
efforts—admirable considering Bitcoin hadn’t,
and still hasn’t, been adopted widely
as currency—were known as Bitcoin 2.0.”
I love this paragraph because it
outlines just how disconnected
from reality the people actually
building cryptocurrencies really are.
They don’t understand anything about the
ecosystems they’re trying to disrupt,
they only know that these are things
that can be conceptualized as valuable
and assume that because they understand one very
complicated thing, programming with cryptography,
that all other complicated things must
be lesser in complexity and naturally
lower in the hierarchy of reality, nails easily
driven by the hammer that they have created.
The idea of putting medical records on a
public, decentralized, trustless blockchain
is absolutely nightmarish, and anyone who
proposes it should be instantly discredited.
The fact that Russo fails to question
any of this is journalistic malpractice.
Now, in terms of improvements over
Bitcoin, Ethereum has many. It’s not hard.
Bitcoin sucks.
In terms of problems with Bitcoin,
Ethereum solves none of them and
introduces a whole new suite of problems
driven by the technofetishistic egotism of
assuming that programmers are uniquely
suited to solve society’s problems.
Vitalik wants his invention to be
an infinite machine, so let’s ask
what that machine is built to do.
[Drumming]
In order to really understand the full
scope of this we do need to dig a bit
more into the technical aspects,
because that technical functionality
informs the way the rest of the system behaves.
In a very McLuhanist way, the machine
shapes the environment around it.
As already mentioned, a blockchain consists
of two broad fundamental components:
the ledger and the consensus mechanism.
All currently popular blockchains
use an append-only ledger.
Now this is, on its own, not that remarkable.
Append-only is just a database setting that only
allows new entries to be added to the end of the
current database, once something is written to the
database it’s read-only. Standard applications
are typically things like activity logs,
which is conceptually all a blockchain
really is: a giant log of transactions.
The hitch is that it’s decentralized, with
elective participants hosting a complete copy
of the entire log, and this is where the second
component comes in, the consensus mechanism.
All validating participants, called nodes,
have a complete copy of the database,
and no one copy is considered
to be the authoritative copy.
Instead there is a consensus mechanism that
determines which transactions actually happened.
This is all the proof of work stuff.
Proof of work isn’t the only consensus mechanism,
but it’s popular because it’s very easy
to implement by just cloning Bitcoin
and is resilient against the kinds of
attacks that crypto enthusiasts care about.
It’s a very brute-force solution,
but legitimately if you want a network of
ledgers where no one trusts anyone else,
just making everyone on the network do extreme
amounts of wasted, duplicate work is a solution.
One of the major problems that this machine
solves is what’s called the double-spend
problem: how do you stop someone
from spending the same dollar twice?
If someone tries, how do you determine
which transaction really happened?
Banks solve this problem by not correlating
account balance with any specific dollar,
processing transactions first-come-first-serve,
which they track with central resources,
and punishing users with overdraft
fees for double-spending.
Eschewing a central solution, cryptocurrencies
rely on their consensus mechanism.
The most popular alternative to
proof-of-work is proof-of-stake,
where validators post collateral of some kind,
usually whatever currency is endemic to the chain,
with the amount of collateral determining their
odds of being rewarded the validation bounty
for any given transaction. The main proposal of
proof of stake is that it significantly reduces
the wasted power problems of proof of work,
but it’s less resilient than proof of work.
On the energy cost side of things, proof of stake
is still inefficient, just by virtue of the sheer
volume of redundancy, but on a per-user basis
it’s at least inefficient on the scale of, like,
an MMO as opposed to a steel foundry.
This is difficult to assess because the
most popular proof of stake chains are still
unpopular and low traffic in the
scope of things, heavily centralized.
Claims about scalability are backed
up by nothing but the creators’ word.
Proof of stake is also significantly more
complex because there now needs to be some
mechanism for determining who gets to do the
validations, and also determining how audits
are conducted, and then the question
of who has control over that system,
and whether or not someone can gain control of
that system or control over the whole stake,
via just buying out the staking
pool, et cetera et cetera et cetera.
Proof of Stake also, even more explicitly,
rewards the wealthy who have the capital
to both stake and spend. It’s also even more
explicitly exclusionary. Ethereum’s proposed
proof-of-stake migration has a buy-in of 32 Ether,
which at the time of writing is about $130,000,
so really only early adopters
and the wealthy can actually
meaningfully participate
for more than just crumbs.
This is, in turn, compounding inherent problems
with the long term growth of the chain.
Even if you solve the escalating
power requirements of proof of work,
the data requirements of storing the chain
and participating as a validator are also
prohibitive in a way that inevitably centralizes
power in the hands of a few wealthy operators.
Vitalik: 85 terabytes per year is
actually fine, right? Like, because, uh,
85 terabytes per year, like, if you have, if
you have even one person that just keeps buying,
like, um, a hundred dollar hard drive, like, uh,
I think once every month then they can store it,
right, like it’s something like that. So, it’s
too big for just like a casual user that just
wants to run the chain on their laptop, but one
dedicated user who cares, they can totally afford
to, uh, afford to store the chain. And so 85
terabytes, not a big deal, right, but once you
crank that number higher there comes a point
at which it starts becoming a really big deal.
The major downside of all these systems is
that they’re extremely slow. Proof of work
is inefficient by design, and proof of stake
has multiple layers of lottery that need to
be executed before any transaction can
be conducted, and in particular suffers
from delays when elected validators are
offline and the system needs to draw again.
As an extension of being slow
they’re also prone to getting
overwhelmed if too many people try
to make transactions simultaneously,
which can cause de-syncs between validators
and even lead to what’s called a fork,
where two or more pools of validators reach a
different consensus about the state of the network
and each branch keeps on going afterwards
assuming that it is the authoritative version.
Forks can also be caused on purpose, and this
is, in fact, the only way to effectively undo
transactions. Like if someone stole your
coins the only way to get them back would
be to convince the people who manage the
chain itself to negotiate a rollback.
That’s foreshadowing for later.
Now, because the nature of a fork involves
a disagreement on what transactions
actually happened, and who got paid for those
transactions, this means that each arm of the
fork has a vested interest in its own arm being
the authoritative arm, so resolving forks can turn
into irreconcilable schisms, which is funny as
an outside observer viewing it as inane internet
drama, but is frankly unacceptable for anything
posturing as a serious and legitimate currency.
Like, it’s important to stress that
because of the nature of the chain,
the way that the ID numbers of later blocks are
dependent on the outcomes of previous blocks,
these aren’t just a few disputed transactions
that need to be resolved between the buyer,
the seller, and the payment processor,
these are disagreements on the fundamental
state of the entire economy that
create an entire alternate reality.
It’s an ecosystem that absolutely
demolishes consumer protections
and makes the re-implementation
of them extremely difficult.
One of the big selling points of all this
technology is that it’s particularly secure,
very difficult for anyone to hack it
directly, since there’s so much redundancy.
A lot of hay is made about the system’s
resiliency against man-in-the-middle
attacks, which are your classic
Hollywood hacker type attacks.
Someone sends a command from point A and on the
way to point B it is intercepted and altered.
Someone hacks into the bank and adds an arbitrary
number of zeroes onto their account balance.
Evangelists will commonly claim
that blockchain could revolutionize
the global shipping industry and reduce fraud.
It’s a good claim to interrogate.
First, the things that blockchain is
capable of tracking are things that
manufacturers and shippers are already
tracking, or at least trying to track,
so this is not so much “revolution”
as it would be “standardization.”
Even that is built on a predicate assumption
that everyone picks the same chain.
It’s an extremely optimistic assumption.
Many, many, many firms deliberately want their
information centralized and obfuscated
to protect against corporate espionage.
The lack of a shared, standardized
bucket to put all the information into
is not because it’s been heretofore
impossible, but because it’s been undesirable.
Second, it assumes the existence of a theoretical
mechanism that ensures the synchronization of the
chain and reality above and beyond the
current capacity of logistics software,
some means of preventing people from just
lying to the blockchain and giving it the
information it expects to be receiving,
the blockchain equivalent of ripping off the
shipping label and slapping it on the new box.
The bigger problem here is
that in the pantheon of fraud,
man-in-the-middle attacks
are actually pretty rare.
Global shipping needs to deal with it in certain
capacities, but taken on the whole the vast
majority of fraud doesn’t come from altering
information as it passes between parties,
rather from colluding parties
entering bad information at the start.
Con artists don’t hack the Gibson to transfer
your funds to their offshore accounts,
they convince you to give them your password.
Most fraud comes from people who technically
have permission to be doing what they’re doing.
Rather than preventing these
actual common types of fraud,
cryptocurrency has made them absurdly easy,
and the main reason why cryptocurrency needs
to be so resistant to man-in-the-middle
attacks is because the decentralized nature
of the network otherwise makes them
acutely vulnerable to those attacks.
What this all kinda means
is that blockchains are all
pretty bad at doing most of the things
they’re trying to do, and a lot of the
innovations in blockchains are attempts at
solving problems that blockchains introduced.
The biggest issue that cryptocurrencies have
suffered from is a lack of tangible things to
actually use them on as currencies, rent or food
or transit, and this is for pretty simple reasons.
One is that the transaction fees on popular
chains are so prohibitive that it’s pointless
to use them on any transaction that isn’t
hundreds, if not thousands of dollars;
no one is going to buy the Bitcoin Bucket from
their local KFC. Ethereum’s main transaction fee,
called Gas, on a good day runs around $20 US
per transaction, but that’s severely optimistic.
As of December 2021 the daily average
cost of Gas hasn’t gone below $50
US since August, with the three
month daily average riding over $130.
And that’s just the daily average.
The hourly price can, and does, swing
by up to two orders of magnitude.
The throughput of blockchains is
so abysmal that transaction slots
are auctioned off to the highest bidder,
that’s why these numbers are so extreme.
It only takes a few high rollers competing on
a transaction to drive the hourly price of gas
up over $1000 US. The internal term for this
is a “gas war” because it’s just that common.
Bots, in particular, can drive
gas prices well into the tens
of thousands of dollars as they
compete to capitalize on mistakes,
such as someone listing something for
sale well below its general market price.
Also, it needs to be stressed: these gas wars
aren’t localized to just the thing that’s being
fought over. If Steam is getting hammered because
ConcernedApe posted Stardew Valley 2 by surprise,
that will probably stay pretty well
contained. If Taylor Swift concert
tickets go on sale and LiveNation gets
crushed, you might never even know.
What those don’t do is cause
the cost of placing an order
on DriveThruRPG to spike by eight
thousand percent for three hours.
The second big reason is that value on
the coins themselves is so volatile that
unless you’re willing to engage with
the speculative nature of the coins
there’s actually a huge risk in
accepting them as payment for anything.
Bitcoin in particular, owing to its glacial
transaction times, suffers from problems where
the value of the coin can change dramatically
between the start and end of a transaction.
This is such a problem that it’s led to the rise
of an entire strata of middlemen in the ecosystem,
so-called “stablecoin” exchanges
like Tether that exist to quickly
transfer cryptocurrencies between
each other and lock-in values.
The stablecoins, rather than
having a speculative value,
have a value that’s pegged to the value of an
actual currency, like the Euro or US dollar.
The underlying problem that they
exist to solve is itself twofold.
One is that converting cryptocurrency into
dollars is the step of the process that
makes you accountable to the tax man,
and the primary goal of crypto in general is
to starve public services, so that’s a no go.
The second is that there just
aren’t actually that many buyers,
and there’s not enough liquidity in
the ecosystem to cash out big holdings.
Tether, the largest stablecoin, used
to advertise itself as being backed
on a one to one basis back when it was
called Realcoin, but that language has
become far more nebulous over time as it’s
become obvious that it just isn’t true.
This is a very complicated situation, but the
short version is that the people who own Tether
also own a real money exchange called Bitfinex,
and there’s evidence that the two services,
both which require having actual dollars
on hand in order to back their products and
facilitate exchanges, are sharing the same pool
of money, swapping it back and forth as needed.
This means that at any given time
either service is potentially backed by
zero dollars, or at least that’s what
the data implies might be the case.
Point is that if you’re a high
roller with tens of millions
of conceptual dollars tied up in cryptocurrency,
there’s a fundamental cash problem. Your
holdings have inflated to tens, hundreds,
or thousands of times what you put in, but that
price is just theoretical. It’s speculative.
You have all this crypto, you
can’t meaningfully spend it,
and there’s not enough
buyers for you to get it out.
In order for you to cash out you need
to convince someone else to buy in.
These factors, taken holistically, mean
that cryptocurrency is a Bigger Fool scam.
There’s a lot of digital ink spilt trying
to outline if it’s a decentralized Ponzi
scheme or a pyramid scheme or some hybrid
of the two, which is a taxonomical argument
that I’m not here to settle, but, like
both of those, it’s a Bigger Fool scam.
The whole thing operates by buying
worthless assets believing that you
will later be able to sell them to a bigger fool.
The entire structure of cryptocurrencies
at their basic level of operation
is designed to deliver the greatest rewards
to the earliest adopters, regardless of
if you’re talking about proof-of-work or
proof-of-stake. This is inherent to their being.
As Stephen Diel put it
“These schemes around crypto tokens cannot create
or destroy actual dollars, they can only shift
them around. If you sell your crypto and make a
profit in dollars, it’s only because someone else
bought it at a higher price than you did. And
then they expect to do the same and so on and
so on ad infinitum. Every dollar that comes out of
cryptocurrency needs to come from a later investor
putting a dollar in. Crypto investments
cannot be anything but a zero sum game,
and many are actually massively negative sum. In
order to presume a crypto investment functions as
a store of value we simultaneously need to
suppose an infinite chain of greater fools
who keep buying these assets at any
irrational price and into the future forever.”
So with all that out of the way,
let’s talk about the ape in the room.
♪ NFTs super-sexy, man it always lures me ♪
♪ I’m too focused and you know you’ll never
ever deter me ♪
♪ Crypto astronaut ♪
♪ Degen moving so hazardous ♪
♪ Crypto what I’m
gon’ dabble uh ♪
♪ OpenSea is like chapel yeah ♪
NFTs, non-fungible tokens.
On a conceptual level the
tech acts as a sort of generic
database to mediate the exchange of digital stuff.
The most optimistic read on it is a framework for
a type of computer code that creates so-called
true digital objects, meaning digital
objects that possess the attributes of both
physical objects and digital,
being losslessly-transmittable
while providing strict uniqueness,
which is an important concept.
Strict uniqueness is a way of
saying that two different things
are different things, even if they’re
different copies of the same thing.
My copy of Grey by EL James is strictly unique.
While millions of copies of the book exist,
this is the only copy that is this copy,
and this is the only copy that has the
very specific damage of being glued
shut and thrown into the Bow River.
[splash]
It is also strictly scarce. While
millions of copies of Grey exist,
that’s still a finite number,
meaning it is possible,
though not immediately practical,
for the world to run out of copies.
NFTs impose a simulacrum of this
physical scarcity and uniqueness
onto digital objects within their ecosystem.
[splash]
On a technical level a non-fungible token
is just a token that has a unique serial
number and can’t be subdivided into smaller parts.
Two tokens, even two that tokenize the same
conceptual thing, are still strictly
unique with different serial numbers.
Within the context of Ethereum
and its clones these tokens are
effectively a small packet of data
that can contain a payload of code.
It’s a box that you can put a micro program into.
That micro-program is called a smart contract, a
name that is so comically full of itself that I
feel like it’s misleading to even call them
that, but I have to for simplicity's sake.
But real quick, yes, that is how the
inventors conceptualize the role of
these things, as the unity of programming and law.
The phrase “code is law” gets bandied
about as an aphorism, and it’s just
so full of holes that we’re going to be
spending the next forever talking about it.
Before we move into that this is the root of it:
there is a tremendous disconnect between what NFT
advocates say they do and what they actually do.
But, and this is very important,
both the claimed functionality and
the actual functionality are both bad.
It’s all broken, none of it works well,
so the idea of it becoming the norm is
terrible, but the prospect of what the
world would look like if all the mythologizing
and over-promising came true also super sucks.
The end goal of this infinite machine
is the financialization of everything.
Any benefits of digital
uniqueness end up being a quirk,
a necessary precondition of turning
everything into a stock market.
There’s nothing particularly offensive
underpinning the concept of digital collectibles,
frameworks and subcultures for
digital collectibles have existed for
decades within various contexts, but NFTs
exist to lend credibility and functionality to
the cryptocurrencies that they exist on top of.
Okay, okay, okay, code is law.
Now, what that little smart contract
program does is up to the token creator.
It can be a relatively sophisticated applet that
allows the user to execute various commands,
or it can be a plain hypertext link to a
static URL of an image, or anything in between.
Most are a lot closer to static URLs
than they are to functional programs.
This is in part because the thing
that NFTs have become synonymous with
are digital artworks, but really what
the token represents is arbitrary.
It can be a video game item, a
permission slip, a subscription,
a domain name, a virus that steals all your
digital stuff, or a combination of all of those.
While the concept has been floating around since
2015 when the framework was thrown together
in a day during a hack-a-thon, and the first
Ethereum implemented tokens were minted in 2017,
for the mainstream the story starts in the spring
of 2021 following a string of high-priced sales
of tokens minted by digital artist Beeple,
culminating in a $69 million dollar sale
of a collage of Beeple’s work in March
via old money auction house Christie’s.
This high-profile sale triggered a media
frenzy and an online gold rush as various
minor internet celebrities raced to cash in on
the trend, hoping to be the next to cash out big.
Over the course of about six
weeks the ecosystem burnt
through just about every relevant meme possible.
Laina Morris, popularized on Reddit as
Overly Attached Girlfriend, sold the
“original screengrab” to Emirati
music producer Farzin Fardin Fard
for the equivalent of a little over $400,000 US.
Zoe Roth, aka Disaster Girl,
sold the original Disaster Girl
photograph to Fard, for also $400,000.
Kyle Craven sold the original Bad Luck Brian
photo for $36,000 to anonymous buyer @A.
Nyan Cat sold for almost $600,000 with
multiple variants also selling for six figures.
Allison Harvard sold Creepy
Chan I and II for $67,000 and
$83,000, respectively, also both to Fard.
In addition to these high-profile sales of things
that were already popular, whale buyers like Fard
were dropping four and five figure sales
onto a random assortment of other artworks.
Corporations and individuals auctioned
off NFTs representing intangible,
non-transferable concepts, like the
“first tweet” or “the first text message.”
Cryptocurrency evangelists jumped at
every opportunity to proselytize this new,
bold, revolutionary marketplace that
would free artists from the yoke of
the gig economy and provide buyers
with an immutable record of ownership
of authenticated artworks stored
on an eternal distributed machine.
You could be holding the next generation’s
Picasso! Artists could continue to earn
passive revenue from secondary sales!
Imagine what it’ll be worth in five years!
This created an air of absolute mania, as it
seemed like anything could be the golden ticket.
Digital artists, especially those
working with media like generative
art that’s difficult to monetize via
conventional channels like physical prints,
raced into the space and, on
the whole, lost a lot of money.
Critics began questioning what it was
that was actually being bought and sold.
Copyright? Commercial permissions?
A digital file? Bragging rights?
In a huge number of cases the answer
wasn’t very clear, and even the sellers,
caught in the promise of a payday, weren’t
altogether sure what they had even sold.
Tons of the tokens did little more than point to
images stored on normal servers readily accessible
via HTTP, meaning the bought assets would be
just as vulnerable to link rot as anything else.
Some pointed to images stored on peer-to-peer IPFS
servers, which are more resistant to link rot as,
similar to a torrent, it only requires that
someone keep the file active somewhere,
rather than requiring the original server to
stay up, but as millions of dead torrents prove:
that’s still a far cry from the “eternal”
storage solution that evangelists were claiming.
The images were stored and delivered the
same way as any other image on the internet,
easily saved or duplicated simply
by virtue of the fact that in order
for your computer to display an
image it needs to download it.
Claims of digital scarcity apply only to the
token itself, not the thing the token signified.
More than that, there was no cryptographic
relationship between the images and the tokens.
The image associated with a token
could be easily altered or replaced
if the person with access to the server that
the image was hosted on just changed file names,
making the relationship between the two tenuous
and flimsy in a way that undermined the claims
that this was somehow a more durable,
reliable way of transacting digital art.
There was also no root proof of authenticity, no
confirmation that the person minting the
artwork was the person who created the artwork.
This is a pretty handy encapsulation of the
way that blockchain fails to solve the most
common problems with fraud, which tend to start
with bad data going into a system at the input,
not data being altered mid-stream.
Artists who complained about
this system which clearly
incentivized impersonating popular
artists, including deceased artists,
were told that it was their fault for
not jumping in sooner, that if they had
bought in and minted their stuff first then
it would be easy to prove the forgeries.
Because evangelists don’t see this as
a tool, as a market that may or may
not fit into an artist’s business, they see it as
the future, so failure to participate isn’t
a business decision, it’s just a mistake.
They’re terrible people.
All told the frenzy collapsed pretty quickly.
By June the market had
already receded by about 90%,
which, incidentally, just further incentivized
the low-effort process of minting other peoples’
artwork, to the point that art platform Deviant
Art implemented an extremely well received feature
that scans several popular NFT
marketplaces for matching images.
The output of that is extremely depressing.
Not to labour this point, but reposting
digital art without attribution is nothing new.
Profiting off someone else's
art is also nothing new.
All that’s new is NFTs represent
a high-energy marketplace with an
irrational pricing culture where the mean buyer is
easily flattered and not particularly discerning.
The potential payoff is extremely high, much,
much higher than a bootleg Redbubble store,
the consequences border nonexistent, and
the market is clearly in an untenable state,
so there’s an incentive to get in at as
low a cost as possible before it collapses,
hence the absolute plague of art theft.
Even the argument that artists
could make passive revenue off
secondary sales turned out to
have a lot of caveats attached.
One, the smart contract for the token needs
to have a function that defines royalties,
so anyone who minted a token based
off of hype making it sound like an
inherent function of the system was out of luck.
And, two, the token doesn’t know what a sale
is and can’t differentiate between being sold
and being transferred, so it’s actually
the marketplace that informs the token
“you’re being sold” and collects the royalties.
End result, royalties are easily bypassed
simply by using a marketplace that doesn’t
collect royalties or uses a different
format of royalty collection that’s
incompatible with the function the token uses.
While a few sellers, legitimate and otherwise,
made off with undeniably big paydays,
hundreds of thousands of artists bought
in only to find that there wasn’t a new,
revolutionary, highly trafficked
audience of digital art collectors.
Instead there was a closed market dealing in
casino chips where the primary winners were
those already connected, who already had the means
to get the attention of the whales and the media,
a market where participation required buying
into a cryptocurrency at a rapidly fluctuating
price in order to pay the minting costs to
post the work, where it would sit, unsold.
This left those artists in the lurch,
where they had to choose between just
eating the losses, or attempting to convince
their existing audience to buy-in as well.
The people who actually won were the people
with large holdings of cryptocurrency,
specifically Ethereum which mediated the
vast majority of these big ticket purchases.
David Gerrard, author of Attack
of the 50 Foot Blockchain,
summarized it on his blog very succinctly as such:
“NFTs are entirely for the benefit of the crypto
grifters. The only purpose the artists serve
is as aspiring suckers to pump the
concept of crypto — and, of course,
to buy cryptocurrency to pay for ‘minting’ NFTs.
Sometimes the artist gets some crumbs to
keep them pumping the concept of crypto.”
The rush benefits them in two ways: first
the price of Ether itself goes up directly
from the spike in demand, between January and
May the price of Ether rose from $700 to $4000,
and second there’s new actual buyers
who aren’t just trading Bitcoin for
tether for ether and back again,
but are buying in with dollars,
providing the whole system with the liquidity
needed for whales to actually cash out.
This arrangement, needing to buy a highly
volatile coin from people who paid far,
far less for it in order to participate
in a market that they control,
is why people reflexively describe
the whole arrangement as a scam.
If you buy in at $4000 and compete against
people who bought in at $4, you’re the sucker.
It reveals the basic truth that these
aren’t marketplaces, they’re casinos.
And, indeed, even through all the rhetoric
of “protecting artists” and whatnot was
the ever-present spectre of the gamble:
whatever you buy now might be
worth hundreds of times more later.
Constantly invoked is the opposite
proposition of the bad deal:
what if you had been the
person who bought in at $4?
Let’s take a closer look at that eye
watering $69 million Beeple sale.
Independent journalist Amy Castor has done an
enviable job running down the details here in
her piece “Metakovan, the mystery Beeple art
buyer, and his NFT/DeFi scheme“ but to summarize
the long and short of her notes, the buyer is
a crypto entrepreneur named Vignesh Sundaresan
who purchased the piece to boost the reputation
and value of his own crypto investment scheme
Metapurse and Metapurse’s own token B.20,
which Beeple owns 2% of the total supply of.
Following the Christie's sale the reported
value of B.20 went from 36¢ per token to $23.
And that’s just the anatomy of a single sale.
The very obvious conclusion observers reached
was that none of this is about the art at all,
but the speculative value;
not what it’s worth to you,
but what it’ll potentially be worth
in the future to someone else.
It’s not a market, it’s a casino, gambling on the
receipt for an image or video that’s otherwise
infinitely digitally replicable.
The thing itself is immaterial as
long as it can make a line go up.
This is the essence of the market,
and a microcosm of what evangelists
imagine they want to see as the future,
the financialization of everything.
The frenzied market around old Reddit
memes was doomed from the start.
There’s a finite supply of meaningful
originals, so to keep this thing going,
to keep the line going up, you need something
more, something less tied to anything specific.
--
In the months since the initial
craze the marketplace had mutated.
The It Thing was no longer memes or
digital works from established artists,
but character profiles from large, procedurally
generated collections with names like CryptoPunks,
Bored Ape Yacht Club, Lazy Lions,
Cool Cats, Ether Gals, Gator World,
Baby Llama Club, Magic Mushroom Club,
Rogue Society Bot, and Crypto Chicks.
These were notable for, again, commanding utterly
irrational prices seemingly completely decoupled
from any legitimate or legal transaction,
and being generally extremely fugly.
This surge generated an immediately
adversarial relationship between the buyers,
who touted them as both evidence
of their extravagant wealth and
their foresight into the future of digital
economies, and pretty much everyone else.
A very common response to anyone using one of
these profile pics, or bragging about their
purchase, became saving and reposting the image
in reply, or even changing profile pics to match.
Spurred by a speculative tweet from
Twitter developers suggesting that
they were working on an NFT verification
system, Twitter users broadly rallied at the
opportunity to immediately identify
people that it was okay to bully.
Tweets from within the cryptosphere started
leaking out, things like Santiago Santos
tweeting things like “NFTs = Identity 2.0. Can’t
remember the last time I used my pic on the left.”
Emphasis on physical traits. Genetic
lottery. Prone to bias and prejudice.
Identity by choice. Unique and digitally
scarce. Representation of values and beliefs.
Of course what Santiago was leaving out was
that he had paid the equivalent of $171,000
US for that profile pic, which probably gives him
some incentive to really commit to it as something
interesting and special, even
though, stripped to the studs,
literally all he was describing was using a
non-representational image as a profile pic.
For about six years my profile pic on the Dungeons
and Dragons forums was a stock photo of a cabbage.
So, not really breaking new ground here.
Greg Isenberg sat at his computer and
decided to bang out “most people who
make fun of NFTs
- Own zero NFTs
- Have never minted an NFT
- Have never participated in a community
- Have never staked their NFT
- Haven’t built on-top of an NFT project
- Have never earned an NFT playing a game
- Missed out on BAYC, Punks, Cool Cats etc.”
A chain of logic implying that skeptics of
the market are just uninformed sore losers.
Incidents like these lent to the very
accurate perception that the loudest
voices in NFTs weren’t very familiar
with internet culture as a whole,
weren’t terribly smart in general, and were by and
large coming at all this from the financial side,
further supported by all of them having “tweets
are not investment advice” in their twitter bios.
In short the same people
who made and bought Juicero.
It also laid bare that the
conversations were inherently suspect.
How can you ever trust the sincerity
of someone telling you how awesome
their $171,000 investment is when your
persuasion stands to directly benefit them
by potentially driving up the value
of their investment portfolio?
You’ve gotta be extremely rich for
$171,000 to not be an extremely sunk cost,
and that’s absolutely going to weigh on your
mind and influence how you see the market.
So for my part I tweeted about several
of these incidents and was, in response,
hounded for days by annoying people with
NFT profile pics who insisted that I
just didn’t get it, I wasn’t seeing the community.
So I decided to go see the community.
My experiment started with the Cool Cats
Discord, one of the communities that I’d
been assured was top of the pile. I
joined, read back through days and
days of conversation logs, watched the active
conversations, and was generally unimpressed.
It was, at best, unremarkable.
A primary concern was still rooted
in the monetary value of the tokens.
“If you spend 1 million on a cat,
it’s not just for Twitter and no
one would be happy seeing someone
mint another one later for free.
That’s why punks are at 120 Eth…
symbols… memes… theres’ the value.”
What wasn’t unremarkable is the
way that I was immediately deluged
by bots sending me invites to other Discords.
So, between the spam I was receiving
and the Cool Cats’ dedicated “shill”
channel I came up with an idea.
♪ Rap crypto, y’all know Bitcoin ♪
♪ I want to thank y’all for checking
out this joint ♪
♪ See I’m Vandal,
the token rapper ♪
♪ And this right here is a brand new chapter ♪
♪ Follow me as I go Rambo ♪
♪ To the moon in my brand new Lambo ♪
For days now I’ve been accepting every
spam NFT Discord invite I've received,
and it's getting dire.
Stoner Cats, Oni Ronin, Magic Mushroom Club,
NFTITS, The Humanoids, EtherGals, Cool Cats, Senzu
Seeds, Pro Camel Riders, Long Ween Club, Stick
Humans, Bumping Uglies, World of Wojak, GenMAP,
DIMEZ, MagicMarblesNFT, Beverly Hills Car Club,
Cash Cows, Long Neck Cartel, Pug Force, HoodPunks,
Gorilla Club, Alien Archives, Betting Buddahs,
Fighter Turtles Club, The Iconimals, Basement
Dwellers, Wizard Man Jenkins, KATI, METAMONZ,
CrazySkullz, BoxGang, Gym Punks, Unc0vered,
Nitropunk, Crypto Bowls, Masquerade Massacre,
Cat Colony, SkelFtees, Daffy Panda Ganging Up,
Betting Kongs, Wolves of Wall Street, The Llama
Farm, Happy Sharks, Teacup Pigs, Cool Llamas,
Mad Carrot Gang, Barnyard Fashionistas,
Sol Cities, Oink Club, Outlaw Punks,
Crypto Astronuts, NFT Worlds, Panda
Paradise, Time Travellers, CyberKongz,
Party Ape Billionaire club, J Corps,
KwyptoKados, MetaBirds, and that’s about
as far as I got before more or less giving
up and finally shutting off Discord DMs.
Now, this is a fraction of a fraction
of what’s out there, but I do think
it’s a pretty representative
sample, and I learned a lot.
For example, the basic psychological
profile of the average buyer is someone
who is tenuously middle class, socially
isolated, and highly responsive to memes.
They are someone who has very little experience
with real businesses and production processes,
thus are unlikely to be turned off by
unrealistic claims about future returns.
They are insecure about their lack of knowledge,
and this makes them very susceptible to
flattery, in particular being reassured
that the only reason for negativity is
because critics just don’t understand.
Being tenuously middle class gives them
enough disposable income to engage with
a pretty expensive system, but also a very
potent anxiety about their financial future.
It goes without saying that
they’re fixated on money,
and they principally understand the
technology as a means of making money.
Criticism of the system is typically met
with confusion. Don’t you want to make money?
I also learned a lot about fraud, and how
to do it both on purpose and by accident.
The term “rug pull” with its derivations “rug” and
“rugged”, all to describe projects that made big
promises but then took the money and ran, embedded
themselves in my vocabulary extremely quickly.
The market is just absolutely
lousy with fraud and deception.
Wash trading, where you sell something
to your own sockpuppets in order to lure
in a real buyer who thinks they’re
getting a good deal, is rampant.
Market manipulation is so common and
accepted that it’s actually considered bad
form if project leaders don’t actively engage
in it, like it’s considered disrespectful
to the buyers if the project leaders
don’t help inflate the resale price.
Also, and I really should not leave
this merely implied, the art is bad,
but not in any sort of interesting way.
It’s bad in a smoothed over copycat way,
a low effort garbage dump from artists who have
largely given up on having ideas or opinions.
Derivative, lazy, ugly, hollow, and boring.
The capacity for original thought long having
been drained out of the illustrators kept in
the employ and proximity of people who
refuse to shut up about cryptocurrency,
there is an overwhelming tendency to fall
back on stale memes and self-flattery.
A massive volume of cryptocurrency art ends
up being art about cryptocurrency, transparent
pandering to an audience that is either deeply
stupid or easily pleased and quite possibly both.
Absent any artistic insight, the vacuum
is instead filled to overflowing with
references to doge memes, Bitcoin,
ethereum, stonks, to the moon,
buy the dip, good morning, and desperate
pleas for sempai Elon Musk to notice them,
all presented with the earnestness and
authenticity of a Pickle Rick bong.
It's tempting to say that my
approach, accepting every spam invite,
was a really flawed way to delve deeper,
that "obviously" accepting invites from
spam bots would mainly lead me into less
stable projects, but surprisingly no.
I got just as much spam for successful
projects like Humanoids and NFT Worlds
as I did for rug-pulls like
Crypto Astronuts and Hood Punks.
On the whole, if you just look at the
pitch package and the sample product,
there's very little material difference between
a project that's gonna sell out 10,000 tokens
in six hours and one that's going to become a
trash fire as the project leader has a nervous
breakdown and burns the mint three days
post-launch after only selling 800 tokens.
Party Ape Billionaire Club sold
out, bringing in about $3.2 million,
and are now flexing their wealth by
partnering with other crypto projects
like the 2chains-produced NFT cartoon
show The Red Ape Family, which just
really, truly shows off the community’s
deep pockets and commitment to quality.
[humming noise]
Deep in their roadmap is the promise that
they will start production on an MMORPG,
a claim that buyers are entirely faithful in.
Crypto Astronuts sold 1262 of their 9485 tokens,
bringing in an impressive $375,000. But as nice as
that number is, it’s not remotely enough to even
start proceeding with their plan to build a full
scale PvP-based MMO. Following the failed mint
in October the devs slowly went quiet and then,
bit by bit, websites, social media accounts, and
eventually the Discord itself all disappeared.
Based off the ostensible product, why should
one of these succeed and the other fail?
The key distinction, ultimately, between a Party
Ape Billionaire Club and a Crypto Astronuts
is that PABC was already flush with cash and
able to manufacture hype with high-priced
giveaways and expensive advertising.
Buying advertising space in Times Square,
in particular, is a specific fixation.
But running a 10 second ad
every eight minutes on one
out of the way billboard in Times Square
isn’t effective advertising, not externally.
All it’s really good for is internal propaganda,
making insiders feel like the money that
they’ve spent is buying credibility.
And if you’re in a speculative bubble,
betting that someone down the line will
buy you out for more than you bought in,
credibility is worth everything in the world.
This is pervasive.
Even in the most established projects, ones that
have been going for years, there's not really an
underlying thing, these aren't fandoms in the
way you would experience them around a game
or a TV show or a book, the product is pretty
insubstantial if not functionally non-existent.
This is where these projects diverge significantly
from the artworks that drove the
speculative mania in the spring.
They’re not positioning themselves as
art that is worth possessing for the art,
as flimsy and illusory as that claim was,
but as ongoing projects that you buy into.
The purchase of a token is an abstracted
version of buying early stock in a company,
a venture-capital style investment in
promises, which is a very significant mutation.
Okay, so what do these phantom
companies claim to exist to do?
Pretty much all of them promise direct
financial returns in some way shape or form.
Sometimes this is just a nebulous
sense that the whole thing will go
“to the moon”, meaning the value of the tokens
will take off and thus early buyers will be able
to resell for huge profits, or more direct as
the project leaders promise the formation of,
effectively, an unofficial hedge fund investing
a communal pool into other crypto products.
Probably the funniest of all of these was
Betting Kongs, which wanted to create an
unregulated real money casino
in which token holders would be,
explicitly, part owners, and also permitted
to gamble in the casino that they owned.
“Betting Kongs is not your ordinary NFT
project, we aim to create passive income
for our NFT owners by co-owning
a casino with a profit split.”
“Welcome to the whitepaper fellow gamblers!”
“Why are we doing this? To put it short,
we love gambling and noticed how a lot
of the operators out there are owned by large
corporations who have no care for the community
of the service they provide… We want to
provide a project where everyone playing
can be a co-owner of the place they’re
playing at and make money from it all.”
Failure was probably the best outcome for
everyone, here, if we’re being honest.
Some promise this in the form of
a more conventional media project,
like a comic book or a cartoon
or a movie, or all of the above.
“We have planned the creation of a series
of comics dedicated to the pixel girl”
“The key image is static, or at least we think so
now. But the squeaky girl is still a seductress so
the image of breasts will be presented in various
variations that our community will approve.”
“Let’s imagine, there are 5,000 NFTITs holders.
There is a 30 million market of comics lovers in
the US… On average every comics lover spends
around 20 USD per comic per week. It means
80$ per month and 960$ per year. The total
addressable market is worth 28,800,000,000
USD. Let’s imagine that we take 1%
of this market. It’s 288,000,000 USD
per year on the base of monthly subscriptions
raised in crypto. This is a cash flow.”
“Nice to see some active communication,
and appreciate the effort (as announced
this afternoon) trying to resurrect
this project into something successful…
The proposed path forward announced this afternoon
is intriguing and am prepared to support. The only
thing I would also like to see, assuming the
project can be successfully turned around
is to perhaps, in addition to some revenue
sharing, have some revenue donated to Breast
Cancer Research. To truly enjoy them,
we should keep them happy and healthy!”
As already implied, many of them promise video
games, often an MMO, but just as often, like,
just the concept of a video game?
Okay, wait, let me word that another way.
They will promise “a video game”.
Like, that’s the promise, in its entirety.
No clues for genre, style, scope, engine,
or platform or how any of the tokens would
interact with it. Just “a video game.” If
we sell 10,000 tokens for $300 each we will start
brainstorming development ideas for a video game.
Now, all of these tend to be in collections
of ten thousand, and there’s actually an
interesting sort of quirk inside that.
The initial format was to mint an
entire collection and just
shove them out onto the market.
The cap comes into play purely
because you have to tell the program
generating the garbage when to stop.
However as the scheme started to
take off and competition rose,
it became obvious that this was a sucker’s
way of doing it because that meant paying gas
fees on everything up front, plus
the gas fees on the actual sale.
So someone came up with a system for
minting a random output on demand which
shuffles the mint cost off onto the buyer.
From there it all took off like wildfire.
Very low up-front cost, extremely low
risk, plus it turns the entire system
into a gacha game with different
rarity curves for attributes.
At best these are all obfuscated
gambling schemes, at worst active scams.
And the payoff of failure makes it extremely
difficult to parse one from the other.
World of Wojak only sold 20 tokens to
11 people and still pocketed over $5000.
Pro Camel Riders sold 114 tokens
to 71 buyers and took home $25,000.
METAMONZ sold 722 of their 9999 tokens to
343 buyers and walked off with $211,000.
Since the average buy-in is over $350, the payday
for failure makes it irrational to succeed.
The interesting aspect of it all,
though, is the emergent fiction of it.
These smoke vendors don’t have an actual
product more complex than the output of
a vending machine in the front of a grocery
store, so they need a story to sell instead,
and so we get this wave of poorly defined
projects pitching a token with an attached
jpg that represents the concept of a
thing that could become a future business.
What that business does is unimportant,
and indeed many of these projects,
successful and otherwise, trade in a
flattering myth of decentralization
where the direction of the business,
down to its fundamental product,
is shunted into the indeterminate future to
be decided later by collective consensus.
Are we a comic book, a movie, a hedge fund, a
casino, or a bimonthly curated box of snacks?
Well that’s for the token holders to decide.
All that matters is that whatever
it is, it will definitely
make the value of your tokens go up,
so you should definitely buy two.
“One thing I learned about NFTs, if you think
something’s going to be a blue chip, you should
definitely buy at least two, because you’re going
to get one, emotionally attached to one of them
and you’re not going to want to sell it, because
NFTs are going to explode all over the world.
And if you’ve got a blue chip today it’s going
to be incredibly more valuable in five years
from now, or even three years from now, or
even two years from now, than it is today.”
On the front of otherwise respectable, or
at least established, brands and people
getting into NFTs the results tend to
be extremely tepid and insubstantial,
even by the standards of NFTs; very low-risk,
low-quality, low-engagement tokens shoveled out
the door to capitalize on a hot buzzword,
chasing the cash that’s sloshing around.
[Drumming]
Tied up in all this, there's an
extremely pervasive resistance to
any form of skepticism that ultimately
manifests as a sort of toxic positivity.
This is all part of a complex feedback loop.
The projects, broadly speaking, lack any
kind of substantial product, existing almost
entirely as promises backed by nothing more than
a screenshot of a roadmap and some sample PFPs.
And, again, I think it's really important to keep
in mind that that goes for successful
projects just as much as for rug-pulls.
There really isn't any meaningful
difference between a Party Ape
Billionaire Club and a Betting Kongs.
Betting Kongs were never going to make a casino,
even if they hadn't tanked, and despite the fact
that they were running billboards in Time
Square PABC is never making an MMORPG.
Both claims are equally ridiculous, but
one of the two made a huge pile of money.
The primary product is ultimately hype,
which is both insubstantial and fickle.
Negativity, both internal and external, can
have a meaningful impact on the willingness
of people to buy into a project, and if buyers
are tepid then you won't get a runaway sale,
and if you don't get a runaway sale then
that's going to turn off buyers even more,
which means the secondary market for
tokens will likely fail to materialize.
This is what makes enthusiasts
so deeply unreliable.
They have meaningful financial
stake in an intangible, volatile
thing that exists entirely
as a collective ideoform,
a story about a potential future outcome, whose
value is based entirely on public perception.
You can’t trust what they have to say because
they’re currently holding a hot potato,
and as much as they insist that they just really,
really enjoy the feeling of a
burning hot potato in their hands,
do they?
Or are they just hoping that you’ll catch it?
This creates an environment of
toxic positivity where doubt
is aggressively policed by both project leaders,
who have an obvious financial interest in hype
since their big payday is the minting rush,
and community members themselves, who have
a speculative financial interest in hype.
While all of that is logical in the pure sense
that there's an effect that can be explained by
an incentive, the output is effectively
a self-organizing high-control group.
Doubters are ostracized so aggressively
that it chills all conversation
about a project's actual viability.
All concerns are just FUD:
fear, uncertainty, and doubt.
Questions that would be utterly
banal in any other investment forum,
what has the team done, what assets do they have,
why should anyone believe they can deliver
on their promises, are treated as hostile.
And the frank reality is
because there aren't answers.
Party Ape Billionaire Club is
just as vaporous, and yet they
superficially succeeded, so there's
incentive to enforce the collective illusion.
This is multiplied by an internal
form of performative etiquette.
Participants ritualistically wish each
other good morning and good night,
boiled down to the shorthand GM and GN.
That seems like a small thing, there’s nothing
inherently suspicious about good morning or
good night, but in observed practice it’s a very
distinct ritual, not merely a shibboleth, but a
repetitive action that signals in-group membership
and affirms loyalty on an ongoing basis.
If you have Diamond Hands it means
you’re willing to Hold a token until
some promised future where the value goes To
the Moon, you’re not a Paper Hands loser who
is easily spooked by instability, volatility,
or the fact that there’s no reason to believe
that anyone is ever going to want to
buy a Crypto Astronut in the future.
The shorthand WAGMI, We’re All Going To Make It,
is aphoristically bandied about even in openly
zero-sum competitions where, by definition,
most participants explicitly won’t make it.
But you can’t point that out,
because that would be FUD.
And if you’re spreading FUD then
you’re NGMI, Not Going to Make It.
And making it, getting rich, is all that matters.
HFSP, have fun staying poor.
These are synthesized into a No True Scotsman
paradigm. The “we” in We’re All Going To Make It
does not refer to we all, it refers to the select,
the chosen, the Diamond Hands and the hodlers.
Those who make it are clearly the We, and
if you didn’t make it, then you weren’t.
People who get angry about being
scammed by a rug-pull or by
malware or by social engineering are berated
and belittled for not following the crowd.
This incubates a community trained to
ignore warning signs and dismiss criticism,
a community with internal
language and customs that
are explicitly incompatible
with outside communications.
Skepticism is FUD from non-believers
who are trying to undermine the value
of your assets and manipulate a crash
or trick you into being a paper hands.
It all maps onto narratives of sin and deception,
a chosen-few who are privileged with
advance knowledge about the promised land,
which they can achieve by holding strong
to the rituals and expelling all doubt.
The end product is a
self-organizing high-control group.
And the results of that are obvious: there
are still people convinced that somehow
someone is going to pick up
the ashes of Evolved Apes
and manifest the rest of the project, a
belief based on no observable evidence.
“You like to ban, you like to ban people,
right, you like to ban people from your
Twitch stream, huh? All you’re doing
is shitting on Decentraland, bro.
I’m sorry you don’t like to make
money here in the network, but, uh,
I wanted to talk on your Twitch stream, man
I probably could have brought a lot of people
on there, and all you want to do is talk shit
and ban people, man you banned me instantly.”
So the question, then, is what
do the tokens actually do?
As mentioned before the token itself is just
a box that a bit of data can be put into.
Now, this box is extremely small,
to the point that even an average cell phone
photograph is several times too large to fit.
Due to the nature of the chain,
updating software that’s put onto the
chain is both difficult and expensive.
Complicated programs need to be
broken up into multiple tokens each
containing a smart contract that
defines a portion of the whole,
and all of these contracts need to
interlink and reference each other,
but with an eye towards the fact that
each transaction that either computes or
alters information requires paying processing
fees, only reading information is free.
The process of fixing a bug in a smart contract
basically amounts to minting a new copy of the
contract and then jumping through some hoops
to re-name the old and new contract so that
the new copy has the name that any other
interacting contracts are looking for,
paying fees for just about
every step of that process.
This creates a very funny Catch 22 where
on one hand is the insistence that the
NFTs that end users buy are potentially
extremely powerful, able to be miniature
self-governing applets that exist in a
web of like applets, and on the other hand
is a large stack of incentives to
put as little into them as possible.
For an example of the pitfalls, Wolf Game
was a somewhat popular NFT based gambling
game that bragged about being hosted
entirely on-chain, at great expense.
Everything from the pixel art wolves and sheep
to the game’s code was stored on Ethereum.
The idea behind the game is that users would mint
a character token, which had a 90% chance of being
a sheep, and a 10% chance of being a wolf, with
a finite supply of wolves and sheep available.
The important thing here is that the character
tokens weren’t just a bit of art and a serial
number, but tiny programs that allowed
users to perform interactions like staking.
The problem is that their code was full of
multiple bugs, and since some of those bugs
were contained in the character tokens, they
were replicated across all 13,809 minted tokens.
A glitchy token can’t be
patched, it must be replaced.
So the Wolf Game devs were forced to
not only re-deploy all their contracts,
but attempt to re-mint and distribute
identical copies of every token generated.
It didn’t go well.
Given the risks inherent in putting
functionality inside the token itself,
and the high cost of interaction,
the most common application
is to use external systems to simply
check for possession of a token.
This is where we introduce another player into
the ecosystem: wallet managers like MetaMask.
In a few short years the system has already
grown so bloated and difficult to interact with
that it’s become necessary to develop middleware
applications that simplify the
process of generating wallets,
switching wallets, and mediating handshakes
between the wallet and external systems.
From one point of view these wallet managers
are the golden key that makes it all work.
They solve the single-sign on problem allowing
your web browser to simply know that it’s
you who is using it, automatically negotiating
permissions based on relevant tokens.
It’s your log in, your credit card, your Steam
profile, and your bank account all rolled into
a single point of contact making interaction with
Web3, the internet of the future, frictionless.
From another point of view it’s a massive point
of failure that contains so much information,
so many permissions, so much of worth, that it
becomes an extremely obvious point of attack,
manufactured by idiots who claim to
be building a security product in 2021
that doesn’t obfuscate key phrases within
the UI or use two factor authentication.
Remember, again, that these people want
to put medical records, drivers licenses,
professional accreditations, and
real estate deeds into their system.
They should not be trusted.
The entire market is absolutely lousy with scams,
and has been since Bitcoin
first gained any traction.
Every single scam structure imaginable has been
dusted off and redeployed into this explicitly
unregulated market where victims
are largely without recourse.
These range from institutional scams,
like Ponzi schemes, pump and dumps,
and insider trading, to middle-weight
scams like gold brick and wash trading,
to grittier scams like phishing
and sending fake links.
Pump and dumps, in particular, are conducted
in broad daylight, since it’s not illegal,
it’s just against the terms of service
of the exchanges that you use to do it,
so the worst case scenario
is you burn your account.
They’ll straight up walk you through
the process of doing a pump and dump,
no codewords, diagrams and everything.
They’re notable as they’re actually
a two-headed scam because, you see,
you might get recruited onto
the pump half of the scheme,
or you might think you’re being recruited
to pump, but you’re actually the dump.
As already mentioned, blockchain is resilient to
direct man-in-the-middle attacks, where someone
tries to inject bad data straight into the
chain, but man in the middle attacks are rare.
In an environment like cryptocurrency,
with few, if any, repercussions for
misbehaviour that stays within the cryptosphere,
man-in-the-middle attacks are wholly unnecessary.
Why try to brute force your bad data onto
the chain when you can trick someone into
giving you access to their wallet,
then transfer all their stuff out?
Every smart contract becomes a
self-rewarding bug bounty where
the payout is whatever apes and coins
you can grab before anyone notices.
And that’s not even touching
on the subject of malware!
Smart contracts are just code, they’re software,
there’s no reason they can’t be viruses or worms,
the primary limitation is processing power.
But, also, it’s a virus that someone can drop
directly into your bankless bank account
and just wait for you to activate it.
And, yeah, that’s right, there’s no
offer/confirmation step in sending
tokens back and forth, someone who knows your
wallet can just drop stuff right into it,
so, like, pin that somewhere in your brain.
The best part about this is that the whole
ecosystem operates on a strict assumption that
possession is ownership and access is permission,
which is absolutely buckwild coming from software
developers who claim to be very
concerned with systems security.
If someone tricks you into sending
them your Bored Ape it’s now theirs.
The only mechanism in the machine
for parsing legitimate transactions
from illegitimate transactions
is the consensus mechanism,
which is only concerned with whether or not the
transactions followed the rules of the software.
The only illegitimacy it recognizes
are people trying to insert fake data.
When you are tricked into doing something
all of the mechanics of what follows are,
by the rules of the system, legitimate.
It’s a legal transfer.
More relevant, however, is the
sheer density of these scams.
The one market that cryptocurrency has
successfully disrupted is the market of fraud.
Think of this this way: a big population of
people have willingly self-identified that
they have substantial disposable income,
poor judgment, low social literacy,
a high tolerance for nonsensical
risk, and are highly persuadable.
People who fall victim to these scams
have basically no options other than
taking to social media and attempting to
whip up enough of a frenzy that they can
convince marketplaces like OpenSea to act as
de facto censors by delisting stolen tokens.
There’s no authority you can report them to
that has the power to return your tokens,
the best you can hope for is denying the scammers
profit on their incredibly low-cost operation.
If your business is tricking
people out of their money
you would be a fool if you
didn’t take the opportunity.
Not only have participants advertised their
susceptibility to incoherent promises of
future returns, the immutable structure of the
chain, the persistence of data, and the ease
with which that data can be collated, means that
for scammers it’s extremely easy to find marks.
Every Discord for a rugpull NFT project is
a roster of potential victims. The ledger
of BAYC holders is a shopping list of
targets. The twitter account of anyone
complaining about what they lost on Evolved Apes
is the low hanging fruit of a very ripe orchard.
And that’s a pretty good segue
into talking about privacy issues!
[Drumming]
A low trust environment is
also a low privacy environment.
Anything you do on a blockchain is, by design,
accessible to everyone who
knows how to navigate the data.
Now, you might be thinking, isn’t that
the opposite of how it’s supposed to work?
I thought crypto was all anonymous?
So, yes, crypto is anonymous by default, there’s
no inherent requirement for proof of identity,
and in fact numerous applications
that would benefit from a stricter
1-to-1 correlation between accounts
and people struggle with this.
On forums and social media
it’s called sockpuppeting,
in crypto it’s called a Sibyl attack,
where users are able to generate
numerous alternate identities by
creating additional accounts or wallets.
The epidemic of wash trading on OpenSea
relies on the ability to pretend you’re
several different people as you buy apes from
yourself for hundreds of thousands of dollars.
Rather than anonymous this is pseudonymous.
Everyone can see what wallets and
contracts your wallet interacts with
based off the long hash addresses like this,
but that hash is only implicitly connected to
your identity based on circumstantial connections.
Of course a big circumstantial
connection would be something like
registering with a crypto-based social auction
platform that intrinsically connects the two.
This makes it pretty easy to see that
Laina Morris, Overly Attached Girlfriend,
paid $153 on March 31st to mint
the Overly Attached Girlfriend NFT,
followed by a $205 reserve on April
2nd to list the NFT on Foundation.
Ethereum whale Farzin Fardin Fard then bought
the token on April 3rd for 200 Ethereum,
30 of which went to Foundation, with
Laina getting the remaining 170,
which she transferred into USD using the
exchange service Kraken in a block of 105
on April 4th and a block of 65 on April 22nd
for a combined total payout of $374,726.
After her sale Zoe Roth transferred
the Ethereum to dollars via Coinbase
the next day and hasn’t touched the wallet since.
Kyle craven minted several… other… tokens, but
for the most part just split the Ethereum from
the initial sale into two separate holding
wallets where it’s sat untouched since.
You don’t need to be some super
hacker to figure this stuff out,
it’s all publicly available, that’s
the entire point of the system.
And in another feature-not-bug arrangement,
remember nothing can be deleted from the
blockchain without tremendous effort.
Now, that’s fine if the blockchain only contains
a contextually relevant log of transactions,
there are absolutely contexts where that level
of transparency is desirable, but that falls
apart when you start talking about using the
blockchain itself as the storage medium for,
like, an entire social network.
Blockchain-based social network Scuttlebutt
seems tacitly aware that this is a bad idea,
like somewhere inside their human brains they
recognize that it might be a mistake to make it
impossible to remove things from the system
when they warn users that anyone willing to
dig can surface any old usernames, photos, and
bios, but that doesn’t actually give them pause.
So, if someone posts, say, child abuse
imagery, revenge porn, your home address,
intimate details of your private life, there’s
just nothing you can really do about that.
If you mistakenly over-share, post some
information that maybe you shouldn’t have,
it’s already too late.
You can try to hide it, but you can’t delete it.
Remember that if someone knows your wallet
address they can just put tokens directly into it?
As alluded there’s a whole scam where you
drop someone an NFT that lifts the art from
who cares, somewhere, but the smart contract is
malicious code that drains their wallet if they
ever interact with it to
move it, sell it, stake it,
burn it, it just becomes a landmine
sitting in their wallet forever.
“Yo, this is fake, this is fake, this is fake,
this is fake, they popped up in my wallet,
I clicked on it to delete it, immediately they
stole 19 grand. Happily I just started this
wallet, but already they stole 19 thousand
out of it. Need fuckin’ help immediately.”
Even on the non-malware side of
things people have already been
using this to dump promotional tokens into
the wallets of celebrities and influencers,
but, you know dick pics are an “any
second now” kinda thing, right?
“Oh, look, I minted a photo of your front door
and dropped it directly into your wallet.”
And you can’t just, like,
delete it, you need to actively send it
somewhere, and pay gas fees to do so.
Revolutionary new vectors of harassment.
The end product here is a massive power imbalance
that’s baked into the fabric of how
you engage with this new world order.
Users who engage with the system authentically
as themselves expose vast swathes of information
about themselves and their activities,
while users who engage disingenuously
are empowered in their ability to
deceive, defraud, and disappear.
A lot of this rhetoric stems from a pretty deep
failure to understand what a central authority
really is, or that you can decentralize
data storage while centralizing data.
Ethereum is ultimately a central platform,
and the fact that a few dozen people need to
sign off on every major change before it can be
implemented is largely meaningless and symbolic,
with the validation network ultimately sitting
somewhere between consortium and cartel.
Every large platform has multiple
internal and external stakeholders
that form a consensus about
the direction of the platform.
Windows is not a single-minded monolith.
Apple issues voting shares.
Google is basically a hydra.
While the network of Ethereum miners and
validators are not a formal corporation
Yet
There’s no mechanism in existence that
compels them to act in the interest of users,
particularly poor and disempowered users,
where those interests conflict with their own.
The movement of Ethereum from proof of
work to proof of stake has been vapourware
in no small part because the
validators simply choose not to.
Because proof of work, volatility, and high
gas fees benefit them in the here and now,
while proof of stake and low gas fees only
benefit them in a hypothetical future.
Because these extremely obvious
pitfalls are what you get when
you let guys like Vitalik Buterin
and Elon Musk design the future.
The sole protection for users of Ethereum
is that the system is so cumbersome
that all but the most egregious
breeches aren’t worth addressing.
Of course that, in truth, means that only the
wealthy have access to justice within the system.
If you take all these different things,
all these parts of your identity,
all your economic activity, all the video
games you play, all the groups you join,
and stick them into one system,
that’s a central system.
It doesn't matter how many different
servers that system spans or how many
validators need to agree before changes can be
made, you’ve pooled all that data in one place.
The proposed web3, crypto-driven future
of the internet is a privacy disaster.
This is why I find MetaMask
horrifying as a product.
It’s a bucket that’s asking you to
pour unfathomable amounts of
data and permissions into it.
It is such a tremendous and
monumental point of failure.
And this is where NFTs really
bloom into their final form.
[Drumming]
The primary use case of tokens beyond speculation,
ultimately, is to function as access passes.
From a web engineering perspective imagine tokens
that are the mother of all cookies and consider a
tracking token that users don’t just willingly
associate themselves with but enthusiastically
drag with them from device to device ensuring a
continuity of tracking across all web activity.
The future version of the web,
built on the back of cryptocurrency and
mediated by financialized tokens, is a dystopia.
It’s a technology that’s built
to turn everything into money,
to treat every corner of our
social existence as a marketplace,
to attach an abstract, representative token to
everything from video games to labour unions.
Now, proponents of Web3 will
disagree with this assessment,
particularly the claim that cryptocurrency is
endemic to Web3 and the two are intractable,
but that’s the practical reality of the situation.
Every substantial project branding
itself under the banner of Web3 is
strapped to the side of a blockchain,
be it issuing governance tokens,
or relying on the chain’s smart contract layer,
or requiring possession of a cryptocurrency in
order to pay the processing fees that
are mandatory in order to participate.
They are at this point philosophically
and technologically entwined.
Less accessible, less free, less interesting,
and substantially more expensive,
Web3 is the vanguard of a million paywalls and
oppressive "code enforced" DRM schemes sold to
idealists as a decentralized system where they,
and not wealthy stakeholders, have the power.
I see tremendous blind spots in a community
that has spent so long focusing on the hype of
an untenable fantasy Metaverse where they're the
ones cowing corporations with immutable ownership
guaranteeing their ability to resell video game
horse armour that they've failed to consider
that the "enforcement of ownership"
can and will be used against them
if and when corporations decide to
leverage their power in the space.
The fantasy amongst evangelists is that
a tokenized economy where digital goods
are mediated by NFTs would give
them more power, that goods like
digital games would have true ownership,
encapsulated in the ability to be resold,
but there is no reason to believe that
this is how things would shake out.
The far, far more probable result
is that the tokens are used to lock
products down even tighter.
The Squid Game token scam is illustrative here.
In early November, 2021, a new meme token popped
up, styled after the hit Netflix show Squid Game.
Over the course of about a week the price of the
token was pumped from a few
cents to just under $3000 US.
Estimates are that the Squid developers
took in about $3.38 million dollars
before cashing out their holdings, deleting
their socials, and vanishing into thin air.
A classic rug pull, but the
truly transcendental detail
is that it left buyers with not merely a useless
token, but a token that couldn’t be sold at all.
Built into SQUID was a requirement that
in order to transfer or sell the tokens
a corresponding number of MARBLES tokens
needed to be spent at the same time.
The hitch was that MARBLES were never available.
No rules were broken in this scam, and indeed the
SQUID tokens do exactly what they say they do.
If you have the appropriate
amount of MARBLES tokens
you can absolutely transfer or sell your SQUID.
Just, good luck getting any.
A game developer can in any of myriad ways
deliver on a “truly owned” digital token
that is rendered untradeable in practice,
and all by playing by the rules.
Rules must always be evaluated
for their power to oppress.
This is a blind spot to crypto enthusiasts because
they just assume that they’re the early adopters,
they’re the ones who will have power, they’re
the ones who will get to set the rules,
and they’re the ones who will do the oppressing.
Consider that any token that can be used to
grant access can also be used to revoke it.
Like, let’s say that I create a hangout spot
in one of the Metaverse contender platforms,
Decentraland, and we call
it the Ahegao Alpaca Oasis.
The Oasis has a back room that only
allows registered players to enter,
meaning you need to have your metamask
linked to Decentraland in order to get in.
This type of gate is typically used to create
VIP areas, places where only people who hold a
specific token or class of token can enter.
Only people with official Ahegao Alpacas
can enter. But, as is well known, within the
lore of the Metaverse the Ahegao Alpacas have
long been at war with the Bored Ape Yacht Club,
so rather than checking for an Alpaca token,
I check for Ape tokens, and then forbid entrance.
Or maybe I just make my game artificially
more difficult for them, or inflate my prices.
Now imagine that instead of running
a hangout spot in a video game,
that I’m a Decentralized Finance organization
giving out mortgages in cryptocurrency and I scour
your transaction history for donations to the
NAACP as part of my “risk assessment protocol”.
Imagine that Nestle is able to track
unionization efforts in real time
because the union is issuing governance
tokens on a publicly auditable blockchain.
The belief that the world will be fairer if
the rules are enshrined in code, enforced by
computers, and made extremely difficult
to change or circumvent is laughable.
It’s not merely naive, but
categorically ahistoric.
This is where a lot of my resistance comes from.
You can create specialized crypto chains
that have a negligible environmental impact,
but the force of that model
is culturally destructive.
The current system sucks, but this is just
a worse version of the current system.
It doesn’t even stop there.
It’s tokens all the way down.
“This game it has a, a good, a high barrier
of entry, so most people can’t do it unless
they have what’s called a scholarship where
someone essentially pays for their barrier
of entry to allow them to play the game and
then they can split the profits afterwards.”
Like, okay, Axie Infinity is a so-called
“play to earn” video game based on Ethereum,
but because Ethereum is too slow and expensive to
interact with directly the developers, Sky Mavis,
created a side-chain called Ronin, which consists
of a governance currency called AXS, the game
character tokens called Axies, and the in-game
currency called Smooth Love Potions, or SLP.
All of these components are
built to function as money,
because that’s what the machine is built to do.
The so-called play-to-earn model is a great case
study in what the end result of the
crypto ecosystem actually looks like.
Axie Infinity gets a lot of credulous coverage
from the press because a handful of people in the
Philippines are able to make a marginal living
by playing the game and flipping their SLP,
which lets Sky Maven turn around and pretend
that they’re a humanitarian organization
and not a for-profit business who makes
money off all the people rushing to buy
a team of Axies believing they
can get paid just for playing.
Now, real quick, Axie Infinity is
a lightweight card-based PvP game
where players fight with a team
of three critters called Axies.
It’s a bit Pokemon and a bit Slay the Spire.
Axis have randomized attributes
and are all tokenized,
so if you sell an Axie you’re
selling that specific Axie.
Smooth Love Potions are used to breed Axies and
thus form the basis of the economy as they are
fungible relative to the Axies themselves.
Matches are either ranked or unranked,
but only ranked matches, entered using energy
which recharges every day, can earn SLP.
The amount of energy you have to
work with depends on the number
of axies in your wallet, and ranges from 20 to 60.
Additionally higher ranked
matches are worth more SLP.
More SLP means a bigger stable of Axies,
which means more energy to play matches,
more flexibility within the metagame,
better team compositions, and baseline
better stats, enabling easier wins.
So the difference in earning
potential between higher and
lower ranked accounts is pretty substantial.
What coverage tends to note and then
quickly move on from is the fact that the
game is extremely expensive to onboard, costing
hundreds of dollars to assemble a basic team,
which has led to the rise of what are
euphemistically called scholarship programs:
businesses like Whale Scholars that
set up a large number of accounts,
give players access to the game
account but not the underlying wallet,
and then pay players a split of
the SLP the account generates.
Whale Scholars, and other “mentorship” businesses,
retain full control of the wallet, and
thus the Axies, the SLP, and any AXS.
It’s capitalism in its rawest form.
Players invest their time into grinding SLP,
and then the owners take half the returns.
Players get to barely make minimum wage
while the owners, who are taking 50%
from dozens, if not hundreds of players,
get to speculate on digital land.
“Look what the Whale Scholars just got. We have
land in the arctic baby! We have arctic land!”
Axie’s energy system is fundamentally broken in
how it promotes this exact middleman arrangement.
If you have 21 Axies in your wallet you
can create one account that has 60 energy
at its disposal, or you can create seven
bare-minimum accounts with 20 energy each.
A high-ranked account with 60 energy will
dramatically out-perform a single low ranked
account with 20 energy, but seven accounts
that are played daily by other people is far
and away the best ROI because it involves doing
basically nothing except collecting your cut.
Even more illustrative, between August and October
2021 the internal economy
of Axie Infinity crashed.
Not absolute rock bottom, but bad enough that
all but the highest ranking players, fell below
the average daily wage in the Philippines, with
low ranked players falling below minimum wage.
Naavik, a think tank and consulting firm
that does deep research on game economies,
has done a pretty deep and thorough
analysis of the Axie economy
and in their write up they identify
the core source is psychological:
players aren’t playing to play the
game, they’re playing to make money,
they treat the game as a job and thus have
little interest in game items for their own sake.
Once they have enough stuff to cover their job
they stop reinvesting and start cashing out.
The price of low-quality axies, the ones that new
players are likely to buy in order to
onboard for the lowest cost possible,
is propped up entirely by players buying them
roughly at the same rate as they’re generated.
This requires either mentors to be scaling
up their teams by buying axies instead of
generating them, or new players injecting
new money into the ecosystem by onboarding.
But the more players that are playing, the
more SLP and axies that will be generated,
thus the fundamentally unsustainable
economic model where an infinite supply
of new players must enter the ecosystem
forever purely to keep the price stable.
If it tips one way or the other you either
get runaway inflation or runaway deflation.
This happens all the time in games,
games bork their internal economy
constantly, it just doesn’t normally
matter because you’re talking about
completely fictional gold,
or gems, or dragon bones.
A truly stable economy isn’t even desirable
from a gameplay standpoint, anyway.
Gentle inflation ends up helping newer and
more casual players by driving down the
costs of things in the in-game economy which
lets those players participate and have fun.
Of course if your pitch is “play to
earn” and not “play to have fun”,
where the optics buoying up the ficitive
valuation of your company rest entirely on the
assumption that players can earn, then that’s
a bit of a different incentive set, isn’t it?
More people play Axie Infinity to try and make
money than play it because it’s a game they enjoy.
This is a fundamental flaw in the model.
If you pitch your game based on earning
potential, you are going to attract people
seeking to industrialize your platform faster
and in greater numbers than would otherwise play.
This is exactly the parasitic
situation that games for decades
now have been actively minimizing because
it creates vicious negative externalities.
If players can sell their in-game stuff
then it changes the way they play the game,
it changes they way they optimize their playtime.
Since the vast majority of games
are openly a non-investment,
a straight exchange of money for entertainment,
also known as a “purchase”,
players tend to optimize their play time for
intangible returns like fun, distraction,
socialization, relaxation, challenge, achievement,
and narrative fulfillment, with absolutely
no expectation that the money and time put in
should return anything other than those things.
The key shift here, and the meaningless
buzzphrase that you’ll encounter online,
is the proposition that the results of
playing a game should “retain value”,
which is code for having a
potentially speculative price.
In order to try and keep the grift
mill running for another few months
Sky Maven have tweaked the economy to reduce
the amount of SLP players can earn per hour.
It is a nightmarishly thin edge to be walking on,
and the main thing it has managed to accomplish
is enabling an entire strata of pit bosses running
teams of players grinding out Smooth Love Potions.
And, like all bosses, they have
not taken the downturn in stride,
and have instead started cracking the whip.
“We do not accept mediocre gaming
anymore. Need at least 120-150
SLP a day, and those who yield more will
be rewarded with additional percentage.
I prioritize those who have gaming experience,
we have a separate program for charity.”
Evangelists like to point to this
as though it’s inspiring, people in
economically disempowered countries able to make
a meagre living by simply playing a video game.
I reject that framing. It’s horrifying.
Our global system is so fundamentally
unjust that people are patting themselves
on the back for generating a whole new
kind of online UwU pit boss who tells
you to grind harder or you’re fired
but caps it off with blushy emoji.
Oopsie, wooks wike somewun
didn’t meet theiwr qwota.
This sucks.
♪ We all gonna make it ♪
♪ Love love love love ♪
♪ Do you wanna make it ♪
♪ love ♪
To the moon!
I think the thing that normies don't get
about NFT bros is their dedication, the
staggering volume of capital they already
control, and how deeply rooted they are in
the culture of the people who operate
the platforms we all use every day,
and that alone is a good reason
for people to pay attention.
They have a lot of money and a lot of clout
that they can use to try and make Fetch happen.
This is something of the
splitting point. Basically
the future shakes out in one of two broad ways.
One is that some new technological buzzword
comes along and “blockchain” and “web3” lose
their sway over investors, the
stream of new buyers dries up,
and the early investors cash out as
best they can, popping the whole bubble.
The other is that they’re successful,
and cryptocurrency is able to crowbar
its way into enough corners of our
lives that it becomes unavoidable,
we’re all forced in some way
to maintain a crypto wallet
to manage whatever coins and tokens become
necessary for participation in society,
providing early investors with a captive
audience and steady flow of capital.
To quote German sociotechnologist Jürgen
Geuter, better known by his online alias Tante
“There are parts of your digital life
that currently you can’t really sell,
but that’s what they want to change. Everything
needs to be bought and sold, everything is just a
vehicle for more speculation. The reason they want
you to be able to resell your access token to some
service (instead of buying or renting it like
today) is to create even more markets for
speculation and the smart contracts can be set
up in a way that at every corner they profit.”
The claims that this technology
facilitates an immutable ledger
of ownership is itself largely hollow
posturing, even from within the ecosystem.
Remember that most of the actual things being
referenced are not contained within the chains
themselves, because the chains are too
slow, restrictive, and bad at their job
to actually store media, and because many of
the things being sold are purely ephemeral.
The IPFS address for any given media token can be
effortlessly minted onto another competing chain,
or even the same chain. That’s not
even right-click saving, that’s
referencing the exact same media.
Why is the token on Ethereum more authoritative
than the token on Tezos or Cardano or Solana or
Ergo or Celo or Binance or Alogorand or Polkadot
or Eos or Tron or VeChain or Ethereum
Classic or Fantom or Stellar or Stacks
or Neo or Waves or Holo or LINK or Radix or
Harmony or Oasis or ICON or Secret or IOTA or
Crown or TERA or Omni or Enigma or Elastos
or Edgeware or Bytom or Fuse or Gather?
If a chain hard-forks, which version
of your stuff is the real one?
Bitcoin is, itself, mired in a turf war
between Bitcoin, Bitcoin Cash, and Bitcoin SV.
The myth of immutable ownership governed by these
systems is predicated on a monolithic victor.
In reality your NFTs within the Ethereum
ecosystem are ultimately just as trapped,
sandboxed, and meaningless
as your Steam trading cards.
You’ll hear about protocols like Polygon that
aim to let you move stuff from chain to chain,
but that’s sleight of hand.
You can’t remove something from a chain, so
all they really do is create a new token at
the destination and add a note to the
bottom of the original token that says
“I’m currently somewhere else,
please don’t move or sell me.”
It’s an ask that’s governed by smart
contracts, so vulnerable to bad coding.
In video game terms they would be immediately
hammered looking for item duplication glitches,
a vulnerability that’s basically
inevitable in a mass adoption scenario.
It’s a system that is at once
impenetrable and brittle, and that arrangement
disproportionately empowers the dishonest.
One of the complications is that it’s basically
impossible to extricate the digital scarcity
concepts of NFTs from cryptocurrency and the core
philosophies that cryptocurrency was built from.
One rose out of the other and they
are basically forever entwined.
One of the ironies of all this is that
any legitimate artistic or anti-capitalist
uses of the underlying technology are
contingent on the tech remaining niche.
On a very basic level, the systems just suck,
being slow, difficult to use, and
generally oblique. For the most part,
to the degree that they’re usable at all, it is
largely at the mercy of only having a few users.
There are blockchains that are reasonably
responsive and reasonably cheap,
because they’re not popular.
Hic Et Nunc is a well regarded art market on the
Tezos blockchain. Transaction fees and deflation
are, at the moment, relatively minimal and thus a
lot of the transactions are able to operate in the
range of five to twenty dollars, but that state
exists by the grace of being 45th in popularity,
just high enough to actually have users, but
not high enough to have attracted too many bots.
If Tezos goes, as they say, to
the moon, then that all changes.
Users adopt the platform disproportionate to
the scale of validators, the value of of Tez
skyrockets, and the actual marketplace of people
using Hic Et Nunc experience hyperdeflation,
where currency hoarders are rewarded
handsomely and buyers are punished.
Okay, we need to pause here for a moment,
because this is actually really important,
but absurdly complex, like textbook-length
subject matter, so here’s the short version.
Deflation is counter-intuitive
because the line is going up,
which makes it look like a good
thing, but it’s only good if you
already have the currency in hand. As the
purchasing power of a currency increases,
typically because cash gets more scarce,
the cost of goods and labour goes down.
A deflationary economy punishes buying things,
as anything that you buy today will
inevitably be cheaper to buy in the future.
If you need to buy things that aren’t financial
assets, things that don’t appreciate in value,
like food, clothing, rent, vehicles,
transit fare, you screw yourself over.
This is hyperdeflation, and it’s not only
designed into cryptocurrencies with their
hard cap on total coin supply, but considered
desirable by their creators and evangelists.
This is what going “to the moon” means.
Now let’s talk about unions.
Using tokens to verify union membership
and participate in union activities
relies on the tech being oblique enough
that union busters and their clients
don’t see it as a meaningful arena to monitor.
Also that ship has already sailed.
Union busters and gig economy evangelists love
crypto, they love DeFi, they love
smart contracts, and they love NFTs.
And why wouldn’t they?
It’s an environment that demolishes consumer
protections and transfers tremendous
amounts of explicit power to the wealthy.
In a lot of ways this is all just a system for
deferring trust onto machines and pretending
that there aren’t humans on the other end, and if
there’s one thing that union busters love it’s the
prospect of an unbreakable individual contract
whose inequities can all be blamed on a machine.
The current state of the web,
concentrated in a few mega platforms,
is the result of compounding complexity.
We used to have a web where anyone could learn
to write a webpage in HTML in an afternoon.
It’s just writing text and then
using tags to format the text.
But over time people, understandably,
wanted the web to do more, to look better,
and so the things that were possible expanded
via scripting languages that allowed for dynamic,
interactive content.
Soon the definition of what a “website” was and
looked like sailed out of reach of casual users,
and eventually even out of reach of
all but the most dedicated hobbyists.
It became the domain of
specialists. So casual users,
excluded by complexity, moved to
templates, services, and platforms.
This process gradually concentrated a critical
mass of users into a handful
of social media platforms.
Already, even within the space,
new hegemons are forming.
Tremendous amounts of capital and power are
concentrating in corporations like Consensys,
who own MetaMask, and Animoca Brands, who have
wide and deep investment in crypto gaming.
OpenSea, the at present dominant marketplace
for tokens on a couple different chains,
is filling the power roles users need.
While the chain itself is, in theory,
the arbiter of truth, nothing prevents
people from filling the chain with lies, and so
arises a demand for not merely a chain parser,
a service that enables users to interact with
the chain, but an interpreter of the chain.
Motivational speaker and easy
mark Calvin Baccera claimed to
have lost three Bored Ape Yacht Club
tokens to a social engineering scam.
In reaction to this he took to Twitter to whip
up a mob that could pressure OpenSea and two
other marketplaces into flagging the tokens
as stolen and blocking them from being sold.
Calvin was eventually able to resecure his
tokens by paying a ransom, because that’s
really all you can do and he doesn’t seem
to consider that from the perspective
of the thieves that’s an
entirely desirable outcome.
They won. Their plan worked.
This happens all the time.
Bored Ape members are particularly
susceptible targets of fraud owing
to their specific combination of
greed and low social literacy.
Looking to avoid paying platform fees and
royalties many of them moved off OpenSea to doing
transactions on a shady little platform called
NFT Trader, which allowed scammers to run a very
simple link swap scam and steal at least a dozen
different ape tokens in the span of a couple days.
The meat of Calvin’s incident is the way in which
the platforms that interact with the
chain are being deputized by users
to be the de facto authority not on what
the chain says, but what the chain means.
It is just a recreation of existing power
structures within the new environment.
[Drumming]
This is where evangelists insist
that the answer lies in DAOs,
decentralized autonomous organizations, a
“revolutionary” new way to organize people,
that will allow for the decentralized
governance of these systems.
So that’s the claim, but what is it,
exactly, once you strip off the paint?
A DAO is an organization whose membership, roles,
and privileges are governed by possession
of relevant tokens on a given blockchain,
and it’s also the underlying software
that executes relevant operations.
And that’s kinda really about it.
So just to be very clear here, a conceptual
DAO consists of three things: people, a digital
machine built of smart contracts, and a token that
allows the people to interact with the machine.
In practice most things that call themselves
DAOs don’t have the machine at all,
and a substantial number either don’t
have the token, or only have the token.
The upside of a DAO is that it makes it
easy-ish to create a formal organization at
theoretically any scale, from only a couple
people to massive pools of stakeholders,
and the program layer makes it possible to
automate certain activities and the results.
If the organization votes via the DAO interface,
the results of that vote are automatically
recorded, and potentially executed.
Though that framing is misleading.
As with tokens themselves there’s
no inherent functionality in a DAO,
it’s just a box that code goes into.
I might as well be referring to all
the things you could do with a webpage.
As already mentioned, many
organizations presenting
themselves as a DAO have no
machine functionality at all.
It’s pretty standard to find a DAO
that has issued a governance token,
the scrip that’s used for voting, with the
systems to actually use that token being placed
somewhere in the nebulous future of the roadmap.
That open-endedness is actually important because
while the claim is that these machines will
further democratize the internet, the technical
complexity that they add, the new specialized
programming expertise that they require,
concentrates a lot of power in the hands
of the people who can build the templates that in
turn enable non-programmers to actually use it.
It’s just laying the seeds for the
future recreation of the status quo.
The Facebook/Google/Amazon dominated internet
arose because the technical cost of building a
modern website rose far beyond what the
vast majority of amateurs could manage,
so everyone moved to templates, and then
to services, and finally to platforms.
This doesn’t even reset the clock on that,
the technical cost of creating a DAO is
already far beyond any casual amateur,
in part because all of this is being built by
programmers, and in part because of the stakes.
The only thing this stuff is truly
good for is managing on-chain assets.
A DAO program can see the state of the chain and
interact with it, so the DAO humans can vote on
what should happen to those assets and then the
DAO program can automatically act on the results.
But that raises the stakes.
Because a DAO can see and interact directly
with on-chain assets there’s the risk that via
bad programming or unforeseen exploits a malicious
actor can use a DAO to access all kinds of stuff.
The risk is directly proportional to
the value of the assets kept on-chain,
and remember, again, that evangelists
want to put everything on-chain.
The hilarious thing is that this
has already played out once before.
In fact it played out with the first
DAO ever built, called The DAO.
This whole story unfolds over the course of
three months in 2016, from April to June.
The DAO was an Ethereum-based venture capital fund
that aimed to use code to create an investment
firm without a conventional management structure
or board of directors, a scheme that’s positioned
as “lightweight” and “reducing bureaucratic
overhead”, but really it just translated
to an attempt at minimizing human liability
for the actions and behaviours of the fund.
This unparalleled expression of
greed made the major speculative
players in Ethereum so horny that during the April
and May presale they funneled 14% of the entire
volume of ether into The DAO’s central wallet.
Now, because The DAO’s underlying code was open
source, experts and malicious actors alike were
able to pour over it for vulnerabilities,
and, indeed, vulnerabilities were found.
However, because at the end of the day
fleshy humans are the ones actually pushing
buttons and making decisions, the actual
leadership of the nominally-leaderless DAO,
horny for money and prestige,
decided to launch in late May anyway.
Three weeks later The DAO’s programming was
exploited and the attacker was able to transfer
1/3rd of The DAO’s funds into a holding wallet,
about 5% of the entire Ethereum economy,
valued at the time around
16 to 17 million dollars.
Now, because this threatened the
bottom line of capital holders,
the Ethereum project as a whole, the
entire thing, was almost immediately
forked in order to undo the hack and
protect the interests of the wealthy.
Ethereum Classic, the arm of the fork that
didn’t undo the attack, persists to this day,
though it’s notably less popular despite
being demonstrably more principled.
Because all the talk about
“decentralization” is a myth.
It’s just words.
At the end of the day the guys in charge, the guys
who built the system to serve their interests,
are still in charge and keep a
killswitch in their back pocket.
Crypto is barely a decade old and organizations
deemed too big to fail already exist.
The whole fiasco laid out
the truth from the word go:
calling a DAO a revolutionary structure is
smoke and mirrors, it’s just voting shares.
You might as well call Apple “a bold
experiment in democracy” because
a baker’s dozen individuals make
the decisions instead of just one.
Regardless of the future pitfalls,
DAOs are also extremely limited.
They are, again, just code.
While evangelists promise that they
can reinvent the social organization,
mentally consider all the problems,
conflicts, and decision making that
social organizations deal with and ask how
many of those even can be solved by code.
Some of them can easily be
turned into computer programs.
Automated bookkeeping, payouts,
collections, data tracking, sure,
that’s all stuff organizations
conceptually can make use of.
But how do you code for the fact that Red
just really doesn’t get along with Blue?
The pitch promises organizations
bound by unbreakable rules,
but how many organizations actually
benefit from that level of rigidity?
In particular what happens when the
version of the rules enforced by code
run up against a complication
that the coders didn’t consider?
What happens if someone with
legitimate stake in the DAO
starts spamming the organization’s
internal systems with bad requests?
What if not enough people participate in voting?
What if the system locks itself up?
What if the rules are rigged?
What if the system commits a crime?
If this technology did see mass adoption, a future
timebomb already exists in the fact that very,
very few of these systems have factored mortality
into the considerations of their structures,
because “what if someone with an important token
dies?” is a really easy thing to overlook when
you’re the kind of insulated techbro who reinvents
vending machines and calls them Bodega Boxes.
Now, all of these hypotheticals are technically
addressable, you can build contingency systems
that can account for them, but then
you need to consider contingencies
for those contingencies, because what if
someone uses systems intended for dealing
with deceased or absentee members to
expel people they just don’t like?
And, again, you can only use code to enforce
interactions that the programmers
make enforceable via the code.
ConstitutionDAO, a hastily set up scheme to bid on
one of the few remaining original copies of the US
constitution, already ran aground most of these
problems as the project failed to win the auction
and is now trying to issue refunds, a thing that
the slapdash machine was never intended to do.
The reality is that most organizations
with any meaningful social complexity,
even tiny organizations like video game guilds,
are too complex to properly express in code.
There’s too many contingencies and contingencies
for those contingencies and contingencies for
those contingencies to account for, so rather
than trying to turn social interactions into code
the DAO is marginalized into only handling
code-appropriate tasks, like bookkeeping,
digital signature verification,
and on-chain asset management.
But that’s not a revolutionary new way to
organize people, that’s just a productivity tool.
The DAO can have a process for voting on
actions, but the moment the outcomes of
those actions move off-chain, i.e. into the
real world, the DAO program is powerless.
The program can’t make humans
execute the decisions of the group,
that’s still an analog problem.
The whole thing very quickly runs into
an incentive wall where it’s just faster
and easier to solve problems verbally, via
abstract trust relationships and promises,
to the same end results.
This is why it’s so common for DAOs to not
actually have any of the inner machine that
would actually make them into what they
claim to be: it’s easier to just not.
Taken as a whole DAOs aren’t some
revolutionary new model, they’re a
tool built onto the side of cryptocurrency that
only has meaningful advantages when interacting
with cryptocurrency as a tool for speculative
trading and managing financial instruments.
The rest is just a gimmick, a slow,
inflexible tool for executing straw polls.
Again, a lot of these boil down to a scheme to
minimize liability on the part of the creators.
The creators of Inu Yasha Token, a meme coin DAO
based on nothing except the ephemeral concept of
the InuYasha anime, demonstrated this admirably
when they were pressed on the issue of copyright,
openly trading on a known
brand specifically for clout.
Their answer to the question boils down
to, one, a failure to understand copyright,
and two, an insistence that it doesn’t
matter because no one’s responsible,
the DAO did it, no humans are liable,
just this amorphous sentient carbon cloud.
“You have a really good way
to explain it about the um
about the copyright issue
that everyone’s afraid of,
because they don’t want to invest in a token
that’s going to be told to cease and desist or..
Right, yeah so I mean, to clear that up
I think first you need to distinguish
between a mark and copy. Right? So
right now on the website there’s,
it’s all custom art done by Steven. Your
friend steven. So there is no copy. I mean
the only person that can really copyright
us right now is Steven. Uh. You know?
What about logo likeness or character likeness?
Yeah, so trademarks. Um, it’s possible that the
InuYasha mark it it could become scrutinized.
However we’re a decentralized autonomous
organization officially, and the token is
launched on the Ethereum blockchain, so
there’s, there’s really no going back.
I’m just a community member. I’m not an
owner, there’s really no single entity
that has ownership so I mean it, it’s on
the blockchain now, there’s no going back.”
And that bit also just so brilliantly demonstrates
the underlying mentality of a lot of these guys.
They wanted to use the Inu Yasha brand for
clout, but they didn’t want to ask for permission
because they would probably get rejected,
so they did it anyway, so now that it’s
“on chain” it can’t be easily taken down,
so I guess you gotta just let them do it?
“it’s on the blockchain
now, there’s no going back.”
Things get funny in that frustrating
way when you do come across a DAO
that’s trying to be legitimate, and
they tip their hand by revealing that
underneath they’re legally a co-op or an
LLC or some other extant legal entity.
Unless your goal is a grift,
there’s nothing truly revolutionary
about their structure or functionality.
Li Jin, the co-founder of a bunch of predatory
venture capital firms that focus on polishing
the image of the gig economy to distract from the
ways in which its eroding labour, has an extended
Twitter thread where she tries to pitch DAOs as
the future of unions, though her rationale is not
only shaky, relying heavily on magical thinking,
it’s also peppered with inexplicable lies.
For example she champions Yield Guild, a DAO that
she describes as “a gaming guild comprised of
thousands of play-to-earn gamers. An onramp that
brings more players into play-to-earn gaming,
it can represent gamers & lobby
game devs for better policies.
Its scale also enables the collective to offer
benefits and protections (e.g. healthcare,
paid time off) that would be infeasible
if gamers were operating on their own.”
This is a tremendous overstatement of what
Yield actually is. It’s not a union, nor does it
function as a union, nor does it have aspirations
of functioning as a union. It’s not even a DAO,
though it does have aspirations of
transitioning into being one. It’s
at best a mildly decentralized cartel that’s
experimenting with shaking down players with
the promise of helping them by gamifying
the process of participating in the guild.
In practice it’s a Discord server that helps
play-to-earn players find sponsorships,
pivot from one game to another, and generally
bitch about how much their jobs suck.
In fact, in response to Li Jin’s tweets
the server residents had this to say
“I've read that through the YGG DAO members
are able to get access to healthcare -- is
this true? is there any more info on this?
anywhere to learn more about what is offered?
or is this still in the works? as a freelancer
i'm always interested to learn about more options”
“i actually don't know that lol. that would
be awesome to get partnered with healthcare”
“Where did you get that info though?
We haven't heard of any kind about it”
“Hmm yeah I think Li used it as an example of
potential benefits and didn't mean it literally,
but nothing of that sort has been discussed yet”
Now, on a functional level most
DAOs use an administrative system
based off the use and spending of
internal scrip, the governance tokens.
There’s a decent amount of variability in how
they’re used, but basically they function either
as proportional voting power, exactly the same
as voting shares in a publicly traded company,
fiat voting power where there’s no point in
possessing more than one, or direct voting
power where tokens are spent to cast votes and
more tokens can be spent to cast more votes.
Typically this scrip can be bought and
sold, even on a secondary market, and,
indeed, possession of it is typically
a definitional part of membership.
Rather than structuring like a union,
Yield’s overt goal for their DAO
is to function as a hedge fund,
using the exchange value of their token as a means
to raise funds to invest into play-to-earn games,
and allowing Yield members to spend their tokens
to gain access to these DAO-owned resources.
In fact Yield is so far removed from
the purpose and functionality of a union
that the roadmap includes potentially
implementing what’s called holographic
consensus, which is a futures market where
participants gamble on what proposals
will or won’t be passed using their governance
tokens as the stakes. It’s amazing if you wanted
to build a machine whose sole purpose is to
concentrate political power slowly over time.
Additionally many use a proof-of-stake
staking system to reward members with
additional tokens with no gate on how
many tokens any single member can hold.
This whole arrangement creates
a system where participants with
only a few tokens are incentivized
to not vote against the interests
of highly staked members, plus anything
you spend limits what you can stake,
and thus reduces all future income of tokens,
which means even less voting power in the future.
Members who possess a disproportionate share
of tokens can afford to out-spend on the
outcome of any vote AND still retain
a proportional future voting power.
At best you end up with high powered voting
blocs, and at worst a functional monopoly.
The internal discourse of
Yield is, like all crypto,
focused on the price of the DAO’s scrip, and not
it’s actual functionality within the organization.
Rather than creating a more equitable,
democratic organization that looks
out for the needs of all its members,
Yield is a scheme that explicitly rewards its
highest stakeholders with more power and access.
Now, conceptually you could make a DAO
that behaves towards actually useful,
worker-focused goals, but you could also do that
without a DAO, because it’s just an organization.
The DAO itself is just a
mechanism of an organization,
and more often than not its involvement
is little more than tech fetishism.
So most actual DAOs don’t resemble
anything like a flat hierarchy.
In fact the ability to buy and sell voting
power, and the hierarchy that results,
is seen as a strict advantage in that it allows
emotionally uninvested members to make money
and gives them a thing that they can reward
people with that will “align incentives”,
and despite the fact that Li Jin is directly
involved with Yield as the “philosopher in
residence” Yield is neither structured like a
labour union nor does it have ambitions to be one.
The point is that thought leaders like Li Jin,
who get a lot of social traction by promising
that their technofetishistic community are
solving big societal problems, are liars.
They love the pageantry of democracy because
it allows them to pretend to be democratic,
because they can paint their
detractors as being undemocratic.
It’s all hollow handwaving
and technobabble to distract
from the fact that it’s just shareholding.
It’s the corporatization of everything, the
conversion of the entire world into claves
governed by power granted via
token possession and enforced
by machines that allow humans to
wash their hands of the outcomes.
At the end of the day every DAO pretending to
be useful is still a forced entry point to some
hype-driven memecoin whose existence only benefits
its creators and the exchange that sells it.
[Subway rattling]
In 2008 the economy functionally collapsed.
The basic chain reaction was this:
bankers took mortgages and turned them
into something they could gamble on.
This created a bubble, and then the bubble popped.
When you drill down into it you realize that the
core of the crypto ecosystem, the core of Web3,
the core of the NFT marketplace, is a turf
war between the wealthy and ultra-wealthy.
Technofetishists who look at people like
Bill Gates and Jeff Bezos, billionaires
minted via tech industry doors that have
now been shut by market calcification,
and are looking for a do-over, looking
to synthesize a new market where they
can be the one to ascend from a merely wealthy
programmer to a hyper-wealthy industrialist.
It’s a cat fight between the 5% and the 1%.
Ultimately the driving forces underlying
this entire movement are economic disparity.
The wealthy and tenuously wealthy are looking for
a space that they can dominate, where they can be
trendsetters and tastemakers and can seemingly
invent value through sheer force of will.
This is, in my opinion, the
blindspot of many casual critics.
The fact that tokens representing ape PFPs
are useless, yet somehow still expensive,
isn't an overlooked glitch in
the system, it's half the point.
It's a digital extension of inconvenient
fashion. It's a flex and a form of mythmaking.
And that's how it draws in the bottom: people
who feel their opportunities shrinking, who see
the system closing around them, who have become
isolated by social media and a global pandemic,
who feel the future getting smaller, people
pressured by the casualization of work as
jobs are dissolved into the gig economy, and
want to believe that escape is just that easy.
All you gotta do is bet on the right Discord and
you might be air-dropped the next new hotness.
It could be you plucked out of the
crowd on Rarible and bestowed a six
figure price by an elusive Emerati music producer.
Get a BAYC in your wallet, hodl like a
good diamond hands, and enjoy that yield.
All you need is $5000 in seed money and you can
buy a Farmer's World milk cow, and if you milk
that cow every four hours, day and night, for two
weeks, why there's all your money back right there
and now it's pure profit (minus, naturally, the
overhead of all the WAX you needed to stake,
the barn you needed to buy and build, the
barley you needed to purchase and grow,
the food you needed to buy to refill the energy
you needed to milk the cow, build the barn,
and grow the barley, plus you actually need to
cash out which isn't getting paid, it's quitting).
This is your chance to stick it to
Wall Street and Venture Capitalists,
as long as you pay no attention
to the VCs behind the curtain.
The line can only go up.
It’s a movement driven in no small part
by rage, by people who looked at 2008,
who looked at the system as it exists,
but concluded that the problems with
capitalism were that it didn’t provide
enough opportunities to be the boot.
And that’s the pitch. Buy in now, buy in early,
and you could be the high tech future boot.
Our systems are breaking or broken,
straining under neglect and sabotage,
and our leaders seem at best complacent,
willing to coast out the collapse.
We need something better.
But a system that turns everyone into petty
digital landlords, that distills all interaction
into transaction, that determines the value
of something by how sellable it is and whether
or not it can be gambled on as a fractional
tokens sold via micro-auction, that’s not it.
A different system does not
inherently mean a better system,
we replace bad systems with
worse ones all the time.
We replaced a bad system of work and
bosses with a terrible system of apps,
gigs, and on-demand labour.
So it’s not just that I oppose NFTs because
the foremost of them are aesthetically vacuous
representations of the dead inner lives
of the tech and finance bros behind them,
it’s that they represent the
vanguard of a worse system.
The whole thing, from OpenSea fantasies
for starving artists to the buy-in for
Play to Earn games, it's the same hollow,
exploitative pitch as MLMs. It's Amway,
but everywhere you look people
are wearing ugly-ass ape cartoons.